EVERYONE THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO A
PRODUCTIVE HEARING. AS YOU KNOW
DUE TO CORPORATE NINETEEN WE
HAVE LIMITED ROOM AVAILABLE FOR
THE PUBLIC IN THIS ROOM AND THE
ROOM ONE TWENTY SIX THE CAPITAL
WHICH IS THE WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCE ROOM FOR TODAY
SHARING. PLEASE BE MINDFUL OF
THE MASS REQUIREMENT FOR
EVERYONE IN THIS ROOM AND THE
ROOM ONE TWENTY SIX. AND
MAINTAIN PHYSICAL DISTANCING.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC PUBLIC
CAN PARTICIPATE IN TODAY'S
HEARING BY CALLING- ONE EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT
NINE FIVE SEVEN. THE PUBLIC
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR THREE SEVEN OR BY
VISITING THE COMPANY'S WEBSITE
AT ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT GOV. AS
WE PROCEED WITH THE WITNESS AND
PUBLIC COMMENT I WANT TO MAKE
SURE EVERYONE UNDERSTANDS THAT
THE SOMEBODY HAS RULES. TO
ENSURE WE MAINTAIN ORDER AND
RUN AN EFFICIENT HEARING. WE
SEEK TO PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF
ALL. THOSE WHO PARTICIPATE IN
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. SO
THAT WE CAN HAVE AN EFFECT OF
DELIBERATION AND DISCUSSIONS ON
THE CRITICAL ISSUES FACING
CALIFORNIA. IN ORDER TO
FACILITATE THESE GOALS WE WOULD
NOT PERMIT CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDES THE ORDERLY CONDUCT. OF
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCEEDINGS. IN
ADDITION THIS YEAR WILL ONCE
AGAIN BE COMPLYING WITH ALL
PUBLIC HEALTH ORDERS ARISING
OUT OF THE NOT OVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. WITH THAT SAID AS ONE
OF THIS SEPTEMBER WILL MARK
TWENTY YEARS SINCE THE TRAGIC
NINE ELEVEN ATTACK. SINCE THEN
MUCH OF OUR HOMELAND SECURITY
INFRASTRUCTURE AND EFFORTS HAVE
BEEN DIRECTED TOWARDS COMBATING
INTERNATIONAL TERRORISM. WHILE
REMAIN DILIGENT RESPONDING TO
THIS CONTINUED THREAT
CONCERNING ESCALATIONS OF
DOMESTIC TERRORISM ARE COMING
FROM WITHIN OUR OWN BORDERS AND
STATES. AS RECENTLY AS THIS
WEEK AND WE SAW THE POTENTIAL
ACT OF DOMESTIC TERROR WHEN THE
COLONIAL PIPELINE A FUEL
PIPELINE THE RUNS FROM TEXAS TO
NEW YORK WAS SHUT DOWN DUE TO A
CYBER ATTACK. AS THIS PIPELINE
RESPONSIBLE ROUGHLY FOR ROUGHLY
45% OF THE EAST COAST FUEL
SUPPLY. THIS ATTACK HAS
SIGNIFICANT CONSEQUENCES. THE
MASTER CARE ROZUM IS NOT NEW
BUT IS FREQUENCY HAS BEEN
STEADILY INCREASING NO REALLY
AND CHOICE IN WHEN THE POLITICS
SHERMAN STORMED THE FEDERAL
CAPITAL BUILDING ON JANUARY
SIXTH OF THIS YEAR. FOLLOWING
THIS DEADLY ATTACK- EVENT
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
AMERICA'S IDENTIFIED DOMESTIC
TERRORISM AS THE SINGLE MOST
SIGNIFICANT TERROR RELATED
THREAT TO UNITED STATES I
PROMISE TO FURTHER BOLSTER
RESOURCE OF THE EIGHT IN THE
START MITIGATION AND RESPONSE.
HOWEVER A SUCCESSFUL RESPONSE
THIS PROJECT. ON THE
COLLABORATION OF THE ENTIRE
HOME IT'S PRETTY NETWORK
INCLUDING STATE AND FEDERAL
PARTNERS AND LOCAL PARTNERS. AS
ALWAYS CALIFORNIA PLAYED A
LARGE ROLE IN THIS FIGHT. THE
GROWTH OF DOMESTIC TERRORISM
AND THE SUBSTANTIAL THREAT IT
POSES TO OUR SAFETY AND
DEMOCRACY IS UNDENIABLE AND
TODAY WE HAVE A NUMBER OF KEY.
PARTNERS HERE TO ADDRESS THIS
TOPIC. TODAY I HOPE WE HAVE
DISCUSSION WHICH LEAVES
CALIFORNIA'S BETTER PREPARED
AND REASSURED. ON THE FIRST
PANEL WILL HEAR FROM TOM
O'CONNOR SPECIAL AGENT FBI
RETIRED INTERNATIONAL AND
DOMESTIC TERRORISM EXPERT. JOHN
BLOWS A KISS DIRECTOR OF THE
CENTER OF TERRORISM EXTREMISM
AND COUNTERTERRORISM CENTER OF
THE MIDDLEBURY INSTITUTE OF
INTERNATIONAL STUDIES AT
MONTEREY. ON THE SECOND PANEL
WILL HEAR FROM MARK COLOR DO
CHIU DIRECTOR OF COAL YES TOM
OSBORNE CAL OH YES DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF HOMELAND SECURITY.
JOHN STEDMAN DIRECTOR OF THE
JOINT REGIONAL INTELLIGENCE
CENTER. AND MIKE SEAMAN
DIRECTOR NORTH KELLER NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA REGIONAL THREAT
INTEGRATION CENTER. BEFORE YOU
BEGAN ARE THERE ANY OPENING
REMARKS FROM THE MOISTURE OR
ANY OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
YEAH GALLAGHER OKAY WHAT THAT
SAID I KNOW WE HAVE UP TO
SENATOR CENTER- BURKE CHAIR OF
THE SENATE JUDICIARY-WOULD YOU
LIKE TO PROVIDE ANY OPENING
REMARKS SENATORS HOPE YOU'RE
HERE. HOW ABOUT ALSO SENATOR
STERN CHAIR OF THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE ON
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT. CENTER
STAR- NOT THERE OKAY WITHOUT
THE SEAKER ON THE FIRST PANEL.
TOM O'CONNOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
BEGIN WITH. NO CHAIR RODRIGUEZ
FOR HAVING ME HERE TODAY-
ACTUALLY HAVING ME IN MY IN MY
OFFICE AT HOME HERE TODAY BUT-
IT'S A OF AN HONOR TO BE ASKED
TO SPEAK- TO THIS GROUP- IN
CALIFORNIA. AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT- WE ALSO POINT
OUT THAT- TODAY CALIFORNIA LAW
THIRTY POLICE OFFICER- TO DO-
GUN VIOLENCE HE WAS KILLED
AFTER SERVING A SEARCH WARRANT.
OFFICER LEWIS BENNETT DAVEY
FROM SAN LUIS OBISPO IS- THE
LATEST POLICE OFFICER KILLED IN
THE UNITED STATES AND- DURING
POLICE WEEK I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT WE A POINT THAT OUT-
I'M GOING TO- GO TO THE
PRESENTATION NOW. SO FOR A FOR
UP AND EVERYBODY CAN SEE THE
PRESENTATION- WHAT I'M GONNA DO
TODAY'S TALK ABOUT DOMESTIC
EXTREMISM AND KIND OF WHAT IT
IS WHAT IT ISN'T. AND THE
DIFFICULTIES IN WORKING
DOMESTIC TERRORISM AND HOW IT
IS WORKED- THROUGH THE- JOINT
TERRORISM TASK FORCES WHICH
INCLUDE AS YOU SAID CHAIRMAN
THE- LOCAL AND STATE- ENTITIES
ON THAT TASK FORCE WHICH REALLY
BRINGS- THE ENTIRE- JOINT
TERRORISM TASK FORCE TOGETHER
TO MAKE IT EFFICIENT. OKAY SO
DOMESTIC TERRORISM ALTHOUGH
QUICKLY- IS- AN ACTIVE WHICH IS
DANGEROUS TO HUMAN LIFE SO A
VIOLENT ACTION THAT'S THE EASY
PART THAT'S THE PART. THAT WHEN
A SHOOTING TAKES PLACE FOR A
BOMBING TAKE PLACE EVERYBODY
KNOWS THAT YOU HAVE THAT EVENT-
PEOPLE WILL QUICKLY SAY THAT
TERRORISM. AND THAT'S WHERE IT
GETS A LITTLE BIT MORE
DIFFICULT AND TAKES MORE TIME
TO FIGURE OUT AND THAT'S WHAT
THE MEMBERS OF THE JOINT
TERRORISM TASK FORCES WORKING
WITH THE STATE AND LOCAL
PARTNERS. ARE THERE TO FIGURE
OUT IS THAT VIOLENT EVENT WHAT
IT INTENDED TO INTIMIDATE OR
COERCE A CIVILIAN POPULATION OR
TO INFLUENCE THE POLICY OF A
GOVERNMENT. AND IF SO THEN IT
CAN FALL INTO THE DEFINITION OF
DOMESTIC TERRORISM. IF THAT
THREAT CAME FROM WITHIN THE
UNITED STATES CURRENT PRIMARILY
WITHIN THE JURISDICTION OF THE
UNITED STATES- WORKING DOMESTIC
TERRORISM VERSUS WORKING
INTERNATIONAL TERRORISM- ALWAYS
IS MORE DIFFICULT BECAUSE OF
THE FIRST AMENDMENT AND- THE
CONSTITUTION RIGHTS WHICH ARE
AFFORDED. TO CITIZENS OF THE
UNITED STATES. WHAT THIS SAYS
IS THAT. YOU CAN'T OPEN
INVESTIGATION THE FBI OR LAW
ENFORCEMENT CANNOT OPEN
INVESTIGATION BASED SOLELY ON
FIRST AMENDMENT ACTIVITY. AND
THAT- COMES INTO PLAY A LOT OF
TIMES WHEN- PEOPLE SAY OH THEY
SHOULD BE LOOKING AT THIS GROUP
OR THAT GROUP THIS MOVEMENT OF
THAT MOVEMENT. WHEN ALL THEY'RE
REALLY DOING IS EXERCISING
THEIR FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS-
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT SECOND
AMENDMENT RIGHTS IT'S SOMETHING
THAT COMES UP QUITE OFTEN WITH
DOMESTIC EXTREMISTS. ON THE
OUTSIDES ARE WHERE THEY WERE
THEY'RE FEELING INFRINGED UPON
THEIR SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHTS.
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS TO HAVE
A VALID PURPOSE THERE HAS TO BE
SOME- BELIEVE OR POSSIBILITY OF
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY TAKE PLACE.
TO OPEN UP LOWER LEVEL
INVESTIGATIONS AND THEN THERE
IS A MYRIAD OF- LEVELS OF
AUTHORITY WHICH HAVE TO BE MET
TO MOVE FORWARD. TO GIVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT- THOSE ABILITIES TO
FOLLOW FOLLOW A LOT OF THESE
INVESTIGATIONS- AND I'M HERE TO
TELL YOU THAT WHEN. IT COMES TO
WHO FIRST MEMBER RIGHTS AND
COLLECTION OF INFORMATION
RELATED TO- INVESTIGATIONS THE
FIRST AMENDMENT- WILL ALWAYS
WENT OUT AND- SOMETIMES- THAT
GETS A LITTLE DICEY WHEN
SOMETHING TAKES PLACE. AND
PEOPLE SAY HEY- THE FBI OR LAW
ENFORCEMENT KNEW ABOUT THIS
PERSON- WELL THEY MIGHT HAVE
KNOWN BUT WHAT THEY KNEW WAS
ONLY FIRST REMEMBER PROTECTED
ACTIVITY THAT THEY COULDN'T
REALLY- GO FURTHER ON THERE WAS
THERE WAS NO THERE THERE AND
WE'LL TALK ABOUT THAT. ARE
GOING FORWARD- DOMESTIC
EXTREMISM IN THE FBI IS BROKEN
DOWN INTO THESE CATEGORIES IN
THIS THIS CHANGED. IN IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN. A IT REALLY
WAS A GOOD SHOW. ARE GOING FOR.
STRAIGHT UP WHITE SUPREMACY
EXTREMISM- BLACK SEPARATISM
EXTREMISM TO THESE RACIALLY
MOTIVATED VIOLENT EXTREMISM
YOU'LL SEE THE WORD VIOLENT
INCLUDING EACH ONE OF THESE
CATEGORIES. AND THAT IS WHY-
THE FBI HAS THE ABILITY TO LOOK
AT INVESTIGATIVE EFFORTS IS
BECAUSE OF THE VIOLENCE.
THEY'RE NOT LOOKING AT THE
IDEOLOGIES ARE NOT LOOKING AT
MOVEMENTS THEY'RE LOOKING AT
VIOLENCE ASSOCIATED WITH THOSE-
ENTITIES. TO FURTHER THEIR
COSTS SO RIGHT NOW THE WAY IT'S
SET UP RACIALLY MOTIVATED
VIOLENCE REMAINS ANTI
GOVERNMENT ANTI AUTHORITY
MOTIVATED BY EXTREMIST. THAT
CAN ACTUALLY MIX WITH DIFFERENT
PLAYERS- WHICH IS REALLY THE
RIGHT WAITED TO LOOK AT THIS
AND WHEN WE WHEN WE GET INTO
THE DIFFERENT- IDEOLOGIES
YOU'LL YOU'LL SEE HOW SOME OF
THEM WILL CROSS- CROSS SECTIONS
HERE. THIS CLEAR IS NOT
TERRORISM AND I THINK THIS IS
WHAT THE PREVIOUS LIFE REALLY
EXPLAIN- WE HAVE A DEFINITION
OF DOMESTIC TERRORISM- BUT THE
FIRST AMENDMENT IS RULE ONE IT
WASN'T NAMED THE FIRST AMENDED
BECAUSE IT'S KIND OF IMPORTANT-
THE PHOTOGRAPH ON THE LEFT A
BLACK LIVES MATTER RALLY-
PEOPLE. YOU KNOW YELLING AND
SCREAMING ON THE RIGHT A STOP
THE STEEL- EVENT AND THAT IS
PEOPLE YELLING AND SCREAMING.
THE FIRST AMENDMENT GIVES US
THE RIGHT TO PEACEABLE ASSEMBLY
THAT DOES NOT MEAN QUIET
ASSEMBLY. BOTH OF THESE
PHOTOGRAPHS SHOW PEOPLE
EXERCISING THEIR FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHTS THERE IS
NOTHING ILLEGAL HERE AND THERE
IS NOTHING TO COLLECT HERE FOR
LAW ENFORCEMENT. THIS IS WHERE
THE FIRST AMENDMENT WINS. WE'LL
GET INTO NOW THE PATRIOT
MILITIA MOVEMENT- IN THE
NINETEEN NINETIES HOW WE BUILD
WHY IT WHY IT WAS THERE AND HOW
DO WE GET TO WHERE WE ARE TODAY.
HE QUICKLY- THE PATRIOTS AND
MILITIA MOVEMENTS THREE
PERCENTERS IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT IS NEW TO TWENTY TWENTY
ONE- IN THE NINETEEN NINETIES
LATE EIGHTIES AND NINETIES THAT
MOVEMENT REALLY BEGAN TO GROW-
AND IT DID SO BECAUSE IN THE
EIGHTIES THERE WAS A- DOWNTURN
IN THE ECONOMY IF WE REMEMBER
THE GAS- CRUNCH WERE PEOPLE
WAITING IN LINES- THERE WERE
PEOPLE THAT PERCEIVE THE
OVERSTEP OF THE GOVERNMENT-
WITH EVENTS LIKE RUBY RIDGE AND
WACO- AND- THAT REALLY. BLEW
THE- RIGHT WING EXTREMISM AND
IN THE SEVENTIES YOU HAD THE
WEATHER UNDERGROUND. AND THE
LEFT WING SO ONE. GROUP.
SHUTDOWNS WITH THE-
VACCINATIONS AND WE'LL GET INTO
THAT IN JUST A SECOND. IN THE
NINETEEN NINETIES AND TWO
THOUSAND THERE WERE LARGE
GROUPS THAT WERE IN THE UNITED
STATES THE NATIONAL ALLIANCE
THE BOTTOM RIGHT IS WILLIAM
PIERCE WILLIAM PIERCE. HAD
THOUSANDS OF FOLLOWERS HE WAS A
PHD- HE WAS A SMART GUY- HE HAD
A COMPOUND IN HILLSBORO WEST
VIRGINIA WHERE HE RAN A
VANGUARD RECORDS- OUTFIT WHERE
HE SOLD WHITE POWER MUSIC HE IS
ACTUALLY THE AUTHOR OF THE
TURNER DIARIES WHICH IN THE
BOOK THAT- TIMOTHY MCVEIGH. USE
THAT THE BLUEPRINT FOR IS
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE ATTACK ON
THE MURRAH FEDERAL BUILDING.
THE PHOTOGRAPH IN THE IN THE
UPPER UPPER RIGHT CORNER IS
RICHARD BUTLER RICHARD BUTLER
WAS THE HEAD OF THE ARIAN
NATIONS ERIN NATIONS WAS A
WHITE SUPREMACIST ANTI SEMITIC
GROUP- BASED OUT OF COURT
ELAINE IDAHO. AND AGAIN THIS
GENTLEMAN OR USE THAT PHRASE-
LOOSELY BUT THIS GUY WAS A
CHARISMATIC SPEAKER HAD A
FOLLOWING OF THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE- BECAUSE THEY WERE ABLE
TO SPEAK. WHAT THEY DIDN'T HAVE
IS THE PLATFORMS THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT TODAY THE KU KLUX
KLAN HAS BEEN AROUND THROUGH
OUR HISTORY SINCE THE CIVIL
WAR- IT HAS GONE IN EBBS AND
FLOWS. IN THE SIXTIES AND HAD-
QUITE A FOLLOWING AND THEN IN
THE SEVENTIES THE FBI- THROUGH
UNDERCOVER OPERATIONS REALLY
DECIMATED THE VERY VERY COMPLEX
CLAN- THAT DOES NOT MEAN THAT
IT'S GONE THERE ARE OTHER
GROUPS WERE OPERATING IN THE-
NINETIES AND TWO THOUSANDS.
SOME OF THEM ARE STILL HERE
TODAY BUT WHAT YOU'LL SEE IS
THE GROUP THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT TODAY WITHIN A FEW YEARS-
I PREDICT THAT THOSE GROUPS
WILL NO LONGER BE IN EXISTENCE
BUT THEY'LL BE IN ANOTHER FORM
A DIFFERENT NAME THESE GROUPS
GENERALLY CHANGE THEIR NAME-
BUT THE IDEOLOGY. STAY THE SAME
GOING FORWARD. THE NATURAL I
INTO. AND HELD A LOT GROUP-
RALLY AT THE U. S. CAPITOL SO-
EVENTS AT THE U. S. CAPITOL ARE
NOTHING NEW- AND IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TWO ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED BILLION NOT THE SHOWED
UP AT THE U. S. CAPITOL. THEY
HAD A PERMIT THEY MARCHED. IN
WHERE YOU SEE IN THE PHOTOGRAPH
ON THE LEFT THE NEO *** ARE TO
THE FAR LEFT INTO THE- IN THE
CENTER IS. A LARGE POLICE
PRESENCE THE IDEA IS TO KEEP
THOSE TWO ENTITIES APART. AND
THAT IS WHERE YOU HAVE A
PEACEFUL FIRST AMENDMENT
ACTIVITY ON BOTH SIDES OF THIS-
THIS POINT- AND- THE DAY GOES
BY WITHOUT IN A BET IT'S WHERE
THEY BREAK OFF AND RUN INTO
EACH OTHER FIND EACH OTHER.
THAT THE VIOLENCE TAKES PLACE-
WHERE YOU HAVE NEO ****
MARCHING YOU WILL HAVE ANTI
FASCIST ACTION. IN OUR KISS
OVERALL AND BEAR THE END AYE
FASCISTS WERE DESIGNED TO
COUNTER THE NEO **** MOVEMENT.
UP THE ANARCHIST MOVEMENT HAS
BEEN AROUND FOR YEARS AND- AS
YOU GUYS ARE IN CALIFORNIA YOU
KNOW FULL WELL- ABOUT THE-
OFFENSE IN. SEATTLE PORTLAND
AND OTHER BIG CITIES WHERE THE
WORLD BANK A PROTESTER PLACE
AND THAT WAS THE ANARCHISTS WHO
WERE DOING- DAMAGE TO VIOLENCE-
IN. YOU KNOW AS THE BURNINGS
DESTROYING BILDINGS THIS TYPE
OF STUFF- WHERE YOU HAVE ANTI
FOR YOU WILL THEN HAVE A GROWTH
OF RIGHT WING EXTREMISTS. TO
COUNTER THEM ALSO. WHERE THE
BIG THREAT THAT WE IS FROM THE
LOAN OF THE PERSON THAT MAY BE
TIED TO A MOVEMENT OR A GROUP.
BUT THEY FEEL THAT THAT
MOVEMENT A GROUP IS REALLY NOT
DOING WHAT THEY THINK THEY
SHOULD DO THEY'RE THE ONES THAT
HAVE TO BE. THE ONES TO STEP
OUT AND ACTUALLY COMMIT VIOLENT
ACTIONS IN ORDER TO FOR THEIR
MOVEMENT WHATEVER THAT HAPPENS
TO BE. AND I'M GONNA GO THROUGH
SOME- SOME EVENTS IN WASHINGTON
DC- THAT SHOWED EXACTLY THAT-
TWO THOUSAND NINE THE HOLOCAUST
MUSEUM WAS ATTACKED BY A- MAN
NAMED JAMES VENN BREWING HE WAS
EIGHTY EIGHT YEARS OLD. SO NOT
YOUR AVERAGE WHAT YOU WOULD SAY
A PROFILE OF A DOMESTIC
EXTREMIST OR A LONE OFFENDER.
FUND BROOM WAS EIGHTY EIGHT AND
HE APPROACH THE HOLOCAUST
MUSEUM WITH A TWENTY TWO
CALIBER- PUMP- RIFLE. AND HE
FIRED ONE ROUND INTO THE- GOOD
THE DOOR WHEN IT WAS OPENED BY
AN OFFICER NAMED OSCAR JOHNS HE
WAS SHOT AND KILLED ON SCENE
HERE. SO- THIS IS THE LONE
OFFENDERS HAVE BEEN TAKING
PLACE FOR YEARS AND WILL GO
FORWARD TO THE TWO THOUSAND TEN
PENTAGON SHOOTING- JOHN PATRICK
BEDELL DROVE ALL THE WAY FROM
CALIFORNIA. TO THE U. S.
PENTAGON HIS GOAL WAS TO ATTACK
THE U. S. PENTAGON THE SEAT OF
OUR MILITARY INFRASTRUCTURE
BECAUSE HE BELIEVED VERY
STRONGLY AGAINSTTHE WAR THING
AFGHANISTAN IN IRAQ. SO IF YOU
LOOK AT THESE TWO EVENTS YOU
HAVE A RIGHT WING ATTACK A NEO
**** ATTACK AT THE HOLOCAUST
MEMORIAL INVITES THE MEDIC. AND
A LESS WING ATTACK IN GUN- AT
THE U. S. PENTAGON- IN TWO
THOUSAND AT THE FAMILY RESEARCH
COUNCIL IN WASHINGTON DC- FORTY
CORGAN'S A SECOND WALKED INTO
THE FAMILY RESEARCH COUNCIL AND
HE OPENED FIRE ON THE UNARMED
SECURITY GUARD- THIS WAS A
ATTACK BY A- A SELF PROCLAIMED
GAY RIGHTS ACTIVISTS WHO AFTER
THE CHICK FILLET- OWNER CAME
OUT AGAINST GAY RIGHTS. AND THE
FAMILY RESEARCH CENTER WHERE HE
ATTACKED US SUPPORTED THAT- BIG
THE- THE CHICK FILLET-
NARRATIVE- THIS MAN WENT FROM
PROTEST BUYING A GUN IN GETTING
INSIDE THE SECURED AREA AND
FIRING A GUN AND SHOOTING OF
THE UNARMED SECURITY OFFICER
WENT ONCE THE GUN WAS TAKING
HIM BACK TO TAKEN FROM HIM BY
THE SECURITY OFFICER WHO WAS
SHOT. HE SAID DON'T SHOOT ME
DON'T SHOOT ME IT'S NOT THIS
PLACE IT'S THEIR POLICIES-
INTO- HE FIRED UPON THE
SECURITY GUARD SHOOTING HIM UP
BECAUSE OF. THE POLICIES OF THE
FAMILY RESEARCH COUNCIL. HOW DO
YOU GET IN FRONT OF THIS SO IT
HAS BEEN HISTORICALLY HUMAN
INTELLIGENCE GETTING OUT AND
ACTUALLY SPEAKING TO PEOPLE
PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY GOOD
PEOPLE. AND PEOPLE WHO MAY BE.
MEMBERS OF THESE ORGANIZATIONS-
LAW ENFORCEMENT CAN TALK TO
ANYONE THEY CAN TALK TO PEOPLE
IT'S THAT IS WHAT THEIR JOB IS
THEY REALLY SHOULD BE OUT THERE
TALKING TO PEOPLE- BUILDING
SOURCES OF INTELLIGENCE. AND
THAT WILL BRING US TO THE
DIGITAL MEDIA ELECTRONICS AND
THOSE PEOPLE WILL TELL US MANY
TIMES WHEN THERE'S AN EVENT
THAT COULD TAKE PLACE AND
THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO GET IN
FRONT OF THAT. IN TWO THOUSAND
TEN I GAVE A PRESENTATION THIS
OF THE SLIDE FROM THAT- THAT
THAT- PRESENTATION IT SHOWS THE
CHANGE EVEN BACK THEN GOING
FROM MAILING LIST EMAILS
TELEPHONE OR CELL PHONE. NOW
WE'RE WE'RE THIS IS ON STEROIDS
RIGHT SO. WHEN WE DO GET A-
INFORMATION THAT SOMETHING IS
HAPPENING THOSE EVENTS I TALK
ABOUT THIS NOW SADLY WE DIDN'T
GET IN FRONT OF THE HOUSE. HERE
WE GOT INFORMATION THAT THIS-
DRUG STORY- BY SAYING THAT I'M
SOCIAL MEDIA HE WAS POSTING.
THAT HE WANTED TO KILL POLICE
OFFICERS AND MILITARY WHEN THE
RACIAL HOLY WAR BEGINS THE
RAPALA- SO WE CASE WAS ABLE TO
BE OPENED UP. IT'S A DIFFICULT-
TO WORK DOMESTIC TERRORISM
INVESTIGATIONS- THAT WE HAVE A
DEFINITION. BUT THE CASES ARE
WORKED UNDER OTHER CRIMINAL.
CHARGES BECAUSE THERE IS NO.
PENALTY ATTACHED TO THE
DEFINITION OF DOMESTIC
TERRORISM. IN THIS CASE- STORY-
ALSO STATED THAT HE WANTED TO-
THAT THAT. IT WOULD BE- TO SHOW
THAT PRESIDENT OBAMA AT THE
TIME WITH MORE THAN A MERE
MOTAL AND ONE WAY TO SHOW THAT
HE WAS NOT- IMMORTAL IS THE
THIRTY ODD SIX TO THE BASE OF
THE SKULL HE SAID THE SAME
THING. FOR ATTORNEY GENERAL
HOLDER AND THIS WAS- FOUND NOT
TO BE A THREAT- HE THEN SAID HE
WANTED TO GET HIS GUN MADE
FULLY AUTOMATIC SO WE HAD AN
OPEN CASE. WE WORK THAT CASE WE
GOT UNDER COVER INTRODUCED AND
THAT UNDER COVER- GOT THE GUN
FROM HIM. AND WE ARE ABLE TO
BRING THE GUN TO QUANTICO GET
IT MADE FULLY AUTOMATIC. RETURN
IT TO HIM AND HE WAS ARRESTED
FOR POSSESSION OF A MACHINE GUN
HE WAS NOT CHARGED WITH- WITH
THREATS. OF THE FACT THAT HE'S
A MEMBER OF THE ARYAN NATIONS
COULD NOT BE BROUGHT UP BECAUSE
THAT IS THE FIRST MEMBER
PROTECTED ACTIVITY- SO HE WAS
CHARGED WITH POSSESSION OF
MACHINE GUNS. A TEN YEAR FELONY
HE ACTUALLY GOT TWELVE MONTHS.
AT. THE TIME OF HIS ARREST THE
A SEARCH WARRANT WAS CONDUCTED.
ALL SIX THOUSAND ROUNDS- FOR IS
A CAPE SEVEN WORK. AND TWO
DRUMS WHICH HELD SEVENTY ROUNDS
EACH SO WITH A FULLY AUTOMATIC
MACHINE GUN. WITH SEVENTY
ROUNDS- UP TO SEVEN AROUND
PROBLEMS HE COULD REALLY HAVE
DONE A LOT OF DAMAGE TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT. I JUST BY PUTTING
IN A FAKE CALL. HOW IS IT
MESSAGE CHANGED- THE MESSAGE
JAMES FROM BACK IN NINETEEN
NINETY NINE WHEN WE HAVE A KU
KLUX KLAN RALLY ON THE LEFT- TO
THE CHARLOTTESVILLE EVENT ON
THE RIGHT- SOCIAL MEDIA- ON THE
LEFT YOU HAD TO DO FACE BY FACE
TALKING. TELEPHONE CALLS TO GET
PEOPLE TO COME TO AN EVENT SUCH
AS A CROSS BURNING HERE. ON THE
RIGHT THIS IS THE NIGHT BEFORE
THE CHARLOTTESVILLE EVENT AND
YOU HAVE ABOUT A THOUSAND
PEOPLE THERE THAT SHOWED UP.
AFTER BEING NOTIFIED THROUGH
SOCIAL MEDIA THAT THAT'S GOING
TO TAKE PLACE THIS WAS OVER THE
STATUES THAT WERE- THE TAKE THE
STATUE DOWN LEAVE THE THANK
YOUS UP DEBATE- BUT IF YOU'RE A
PERSON WHO BELIEVE THE STATUE
SHOULD STAY UP FOR HISTORICAL
PURPOSES. AND YOUR MARCHING
DOWN THE THIS- COLLEGE CAMPUS
AND YOU HEAR PEOPLE CHANTING
JEWS WILL NOT REPLACE US AND
FIRE UP THE OVENS BOYS. YOU
SHOULD BLOW OUT YOUR TORCH AND
GO HOME AND THE FACT THAT THEY
HAD TORCHES- SAYSTHAT THERE IS
SOME FINANCING VETS BECAUSE IF
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE A PICNIC
IN YOUR HOUSE AND YOU GO BY.
TIKI TORCHES THEY'RE NOT CHEAP
BY A THOUSAND OF THEM IT ADDS
UP TO A LOT OF MONEY SO THERE'S
SOMEWHERE THERE IS FUNDING
COMING TO THIS. POTENTIALLY
FROM OVERSEAS ADVERSARIES. OR
THROUGH SALES OF MEMORABILIA.
AND STUFF WITHIN THE UNITED
STATES ITSELF. SO THE
COMMUNICATION CHANGE THAT MADE
ALL OF THIS TAKING EXTREMISM
THAT WE HAVE IN THE UNITED
STATES AND PUTTING GASOLINE ON
THAT FIRE. I COULD CHANGE THIS
LIGHT EVERY SINGLE DAY BECAUSE
EACH ONE OF THESE. DIFFERENT
PLATFORMS HAS EITHER DEEP
PLATFORM BUT- LOCATIONS OR-
GROUPS OR THEY'VE- GONE ALONG
THE WAY THE- THE WAY OF THE
DODO BIRD AND ARE NO LONGER
THERE BUT THEY CHANGED. AND
THEIR THEIR STOOD UP AGAIN AS
YOU SEE. THE PLATFORMING TAKING
PLACE YOU'LL SEE THE PLATFORM
BEING SET UP UNDER A DIFFERENT-
ENTITIES- TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN IN CHARLOTTESVILLE.
HEATHER HIGHER WITH KILLED.
WHEN A CAR WAS DRIVEN INTO A
CROWD- THIS WAS CLEARLY
SOMETHING THAT FIT THE
DEFINITION OF DOMESTIC
TERRORISM- THE DRIVER WAS
CHARGED WITH. HOMICIDE HE WAS
CHARGED WITH WITH- HATE CRIMES
BUT HE WAS NEVER CHARGED WITH
DOMESTIC TERRORISM BECAUSE AS I
SAID THERE IS NO PENALTY
ATTACHED TO THE DEFINITION OF
DOMESTIC TERRORISM. I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THERE
SHOULD BE ONE FEDERALLY.
CURRENTLY THERE IS NOT ONE-
REPUBLICAN BASEBALL SHOOTING IN
JUNE OF TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN.
A PERSON WHO WENT FROM TAX PRO
TESTING. TO SHOWING UP AT A
BASEBALL FIELD IN ALEXANDRIA
VIRGINIA ASKING IF THIS WAS THE
REPUBLICANS OR THE DEMOCRATS
AND THEN OPENING FIRE WITH A
LONG WEAPON- THIS FITS THE
DEFINITION OF DOMESTIC
TERRORISM CLEARLY. AS THOSE
LAWMAKERS- WERE WERE ATTACKED
BECAUSE OF THEIR POLITICAL
VIEWS AND THAT THE- BALK FORCE
OR VIOLENCE WAS DONE TO-
INFLUENCE THE POLICY OF A
GOVERNMENT. THREE OF LIFE YOU
ROBERT POWERS THANKS. AND GAB
HAD A FOLLOWING ON GAB ACTUALLY
LIVE STREAMED HIS- HIS GOING
INTO THE TREE OF LIFE. AND
KILLED ELEVEN PARISHIONERS OR
FOLLOWERS AT THE TREE OF LIFE
SYNAGOGUE. IN A IN A CASE THAT
IS A- IT'S- DISGUSTING HE
ACTUALLY WENT IN THERE AND
HUNTED DOWN PEOPLE- IN HIS
FOLLOWING ON GAB WAS WAS- WAS.
YOU KNOW TEARING HIM OUT AS HE
WAS DOING THIS- TWO OF THEM THE
PEOPLE WHO WERE CHEERING A
MONOMER FOLLOWERS IN HIM LIVED
IN WASHINGTON DC. THE TWO
BROTHERS THAT ARE CIRCLED IN
THE- TOP LEFT- THE CLARK
BROTHERS- THE JANE THE JAMES
ALEX FIELD IN THE FRONT LEFT
THAT'S THE DRIVER FROM
CHARLOTTESVILLE THE KILLED
HEATHER HIGHER SO YOU CAN SEE
THE CONNECTIONS THROUGH SOCIAL
MEDIA. AND IN PERSON EVENTS-
HOW THIS TAKES PLACE ON THE
RIGHT IS- THE RICHARD SPENCER
LEADER OF THE ALT RIGHT WITH.
THE CLARK BROTHERS IN FRONT OF
THE WHITE HOUSE. THE SHOOTING
THE L. EN EL PASO OF THE
WALMART THAT MOVED- HOMICIDES
BY RIGHT WING EXTREMISTS WHITE
SUPREMACISTS- IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN TO FIFTY ONE MURDERS
THE MOST- SINCE THE HATE CRIMES
BEGAN BEING TRACKED- BOOGALOO
BOYS BOOGALOO BOYS ARE A GROUP
THAT IS ANTI GOVERNMENT. VERY
STRONG ANTI POLICE- THEY
STARTED SHOWING UP AROUND THE
ANTI VACCINE SECOND AMENDMENT-
OFFENSE IN VIRGINIA AND
MICHIGAN. AND IN CALIFORNIA IN
OAKLAND A BLUE BOY KILLED A
FEDERAL PROTECTIVE OFFICER AT
THE OAKLAND COURTHOUSE AND
THEN- KILLED A SHERIFF'S WHEN.
POLICE RAIDED HIS- FAMILY
HOUSE- IN HERE'S I THESE
EXPLOSIVE DEVICES AND A LONG
WEAPON- TO DO HIS CRIMES HE WAS
A FOLLOWER OF THE BOOGALOO
MOVEMENT- PROUD BOYS WE HEAR A
LOT ABOUT THE PROBLEM OR IS
THERE REALLY THE FIGHT- TEAM OF
THE RIGHT FOR THEIR MORE- LIKE
THE- HOOLIGANS THAT- IN EUROPE-
THERE THERE THERE TO COUNTER
THE ANARCHIST. AS WE SAW OVER
THE SUMMER THE VIOLENCE THAT
CAME OUTSIDE OF THE BLACK LIVES
MATTER EVENTS- WE SAW THE PROUD
BOYS REALLY STANDING UP TO THAT
AND BEING THE GROUP WHICH
WHICH- SELF DESCRIBED COUNTER
OF THE- THE ANARCHIST MOVEMENT
IN THE THAT WAS FALLING OUTSIDE
THE BLACK LIVES MATTER.
PROTESTS PATRIOTS THREE
PERCENTERS- I'VE WAY EVERY
TALKED ABOUT EARLIER THEY AGAIN
SEE THE DOWNSIDE DOWNSIDE OF
THE ECONOMY RIGHT NOW- THERE
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE GOING
TO TAKE- THEIR PERSONAL. ISSUES
AND YOU CAN'T BLAME YOURSELF
FOR THE THINGS YOU HAVE TO
BLAME THE GOVERNMENT AND SO
YOU'RE SEEING THAT THE RISE IN
THE PATRIOT AND 3% OR MOVEMENT-
THROW INTO THE MIX- CONSPIRACY
THEORIES THE MAIN ONE CURRENTLY
IS Q. ANON. WHERE WE GO ONE WE
GO ALL- THIS HAS. THOUSANDS OF
FOLLOWERS ONLINE- AND KNOW WHAT
IS HAPPENING TO THEM NOW AS
THAT WHAT THEY BELIEVE WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN WITH THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
AT THE TIME DONALD TRUMP WAS
GOING TO STAY IN OFFICE HE
DIDN'T- THIS IS A GROUP THAT.
THAT BELIEVES THAT- THAT-
DEMOCRATS AND LEFTISTS ARE
ACTUALLY- KIDNAPPING CHILDREN
DRINKING THEIR BLOOD FOR POWER-
BUT THERE IF THEY HAVE A AN
ENORMOUS FOLLOWING- IN THE
UNITED STATES AND OVERSEAS. I'M
ON TOP OF THE CONSPIRACY
THEORIES YOU HAVE ADDITIONAL
ONES THAT GO ALONG WITH THE
VACCINE AND TO BE A PANDEMIC
WHICH WE'RE DEALING WITH FIVE
G. TECHNOLOGY- THERE'S A
CONSPIRACY THEORY THAT THAT
BELIEVES THAT BILL GATES. ARE
WHO HAD SPOKEN ABOUT- PANDEMICS
IN ILLNESSES AND THE NEED FOR
VACCINATIONS. FOR YEARS- THAT-
THAT BILL GATES WAS THE START
WHAT OF THE- PANDEMIC AND HE
DID SO BECAUSE HE WAS GOING TO
USE THE VACCINATIONS WHICH
WE'RE GETTING- TO IMPLANT A
CHIP INTO ALL OF THE CITIZENS.
AND PEOPLE AROUND THE WORLD AND
THEN THE FIVE G. TOWERS RETRACT
THEM- YOU KNOW. THERE ARE
PEOPLE THAT BELIEVE THESE
THINGS AND YOU'LL SEEING YOU'RE
SEEING Q. ONE ON GO FROM THE-
STOP THE STEEL TO THE
VACCINATION- THE BANKING THAT
IT IS IT IS A BAD FORESTED
THERE'S- ALL SORTS OF THINGS TO
GO ALONG WITH THAT AN
EXPLORATION OF THEM. ANYTHING
GOES TO- TO MAKE THE FALSE
SOCIETY. THE ATTACK IN THE
CAPITAL INSIDE THERE WE HAD Q.
FOLLOWERS WE HAD NEO **** ANTI
GOVERNMENT GROUPS- AND ENGINES
FOLLOWERS WHO WERE WERE LED
THERE BY THE RHETORIC ONLINE.
SO SOCIAL MEDIA HAS REALLY
BECOME BE THE CATALYST FOR WHY-
WHAT WAS ALREADY THERE IN THE
NINETEEN NINETIES AND TWO
THOUSANDS. IS WHERE IT IS TODAY
BECAUSE OF THE ABILITY TO
COMMUNICATE IN. SUCH A
IMMEDIATE WAY- AND WITH THAT
WILL- WILL STAY IN AND- GO TO-
YOUR NEXT. OR ITS IT BACK IN
AND- AND WATCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TOM FOR- YOUR-
PRESENTATION NOW MOVE OVER TO
JASON LAS VEGAS DIRECTOR OF THE
CENTER ON TERRORISM EXTREMISM
AND COUNTERTERRORISM CENTER OF
THE MIDDLEBURY INSTITUTE OF
INTERNATIONAL STUDIES AT
MONTEREY JASON READY. GREAT TO
BE HERE THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK WITH YOU ALL TODAY- IT'S
GREAT TO BE IN THE ROOM WITH
TOM CONNOR. I AM A SENIOR
RESEARCH FELLOW AT THE
SUPERCENTER IN I'M IN MY OFFICE
HERE IN MONTEREY CALIFORNIA
MILITARY INSTITUTE SO I'M I'M
NOT TOO FAR FROM YOU I WISH I
COULD BE IN THE ROOM WITH YOU
ALL- BUT- COBIT OBVIOUSLY
PREVENT THAT FROM OCCURRING. SO
WE'RE GONNA JUMP RIGHT INTO THE
AGENDA- FIRST I'M GOING TO
EXAMINE SPECIFIC RISKS RELATED
TO THOSE WHO ARE FIRST
RESPONDERS IN THE CONTEXT OF
THE THREAT TODAY AS IT'S POSED
BY DOMESTIC EXTREMISTS AND-
EXTREMISTS WHO REMAIN INSPIRED
BY FOREIGN TERRORIST
ORGANIZATIONS WHO AS THE NAME
IMPLIES ARE PRIMARILY BASED
OVERSEAS. THEN I WILL BE REALLY
FOCUSED QUITE SIGNIFICANTLY ON.
THE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SCREAMS A
LANDSCAPE- AUGMENTING- SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT TOM HELPLESSLY-
STARTED US OFF WITH TODAY AND
THEN AT THE END OF MY
PRESENTATION I'M I'LL GO INTO
SOME CONCLUDING THOUGHTS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS. FOR US TO
CONSIDER. SO IN THE- TWENTY
TWENTY TIME PERIOD IN JANUARY-
THE NATIONAL COUNTERTERRORISM
CENTER- PRODUCED A REALLY GOOD
PRODUCT REGARDING DEATH THREATS
SPECIFICALLY POSED TO. LAW
ENFORCEMENT FIREFIGHTERS. EMTS
AND PARAMEDICS AND IN THAT
REPORT THEY TALK ABOUT THE
POSSIBILITY OF AMBUSH ATTACKS
THAT COULD THREATEN THE LIVES
OF THESE TYPES OF INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE ON THE FRONT LINES
TRYING TO PROTECT PEOPLE. AND
TO SPECIFIC KINDS OF ATTACKS
AMBUSH ATTACKS SPECIFICALLY
WERE HIGHLIGHTED AS A THREAT TO
FIRST RESPONDERS ONE WAS THE
LORING AMBUSH ATTACK WHICH IS A
PREMEDITATED ATTACK. IN WHICH
THE OFFENDER LAWRENSON
UNSUSPECTING TARGET TO A
LOCATION TO EXECUTE ATTACK. AND
THEN THERE IS THE OPPORTUNISTIC
AMBUSH ATTACK WHICH IS AN
UNPROVOKED ATTACK WITHOUT
REALLY ANY LONG TERM PLANNING
THAT THE OFFENDER CONSIDERS. A
CRIME OF OPPORTUNITY AND MAKE
THAT DECISION IF THERE AT THAT
SPOT TO CARRY OUT THE SURPRISE
ATTACK AGAINST THE TARGET-
THESE KINDS OF ATTACKS. ARE
PROBLEMATIC TO SAY THE LEAST
BUT ALSO THERE ARE THE
POSSIBILITIES OF SECONDARY
EXPLOSIVE DEVICES THAT COULD
TARGET FIRST RESPONDERS AND
ONLOOKERS AFTER THE INITIAL
TACK. TEARS MAY ACTUALLY TRY TO
CARRY OUT A SPECIFIC ATTACK AND
THEN AGAIN A SECOND ATTACK
AGAINST THE FIRST RESPONDERS
WHO ARE RESPONDING TO THAT
FIRST ATTACK IN THAT ATTACK.
COULD NOT BE IN THE SECONDARY
ATTACKS COULD INCLUDE. ANY
NUMBER OF- ACTIVITIES EXPLOSIVE
DEVICES ON COULD BE HIDDEN IN
BACKPACKS GARBAGE CANS
MAILBOXES AND IN THIS IS A
THREAT TO FIRST. RESPONDERS YOU
ALSO. GOOD HAVE NOT TERRORISTS-
IN PERSON EIGHT ESSENTIALLY
RESP THEN PERHAPS BEST EXAMPLE
I CAN RECALL OF THIS WITHIN THE
LAST TEN YEARS WAS IN NORWAY
WHERE- A WHITE SUPREMACIST BY
NAME THE ANDERS BREIVIK CARRIED
OUT A TERRIBLE. ATTACK IN
NORWAY THAT RESULTED IN MANY
DEATHS SIXTY EIGHT OF WHICH-
HAPPENED ON THIS ISLAND IN A
TOYOTA WHERE BREIVIK WAS
DRESSED AS A POLICE OFFICER AND
WENT AND HUNTED THE CHILDREN ON
THAT ISLAND. ONE BY ONE
IMPERSONATING ESSENTIALLY THE-
I'M BEING ASKED TO STEP WHY DID
MY SCREEN A LITTLE BIT
HOPEFULLY THAT YOU CAN SEE IT A
LITTLE BIT BETTER THERE- THE
IT'S IMPERSONATING. A POLICE
OFFICER IS ANOTHER MECHANISM WE
NEED TO BE WORRIED ABOUT IN THE
CONTEXT OF. AMBUSH RELATED
ATTACKS AND THEN FINALLY-
SHOULD BE AWARE AS WELL OF-
ATTACKS IN WHICH- AMBULANCES OR
OTHER KINDS OF- PERSONNEL
REPORT ENTITY TO AN EQUITY
ORIENTED- WHERE THE ACTUAL
ACTIVITIES THE FIRST RESPONDERS
CAN BE CO OPTED IN HOUSTON.
THERE REALLY TWO EXAMPLES OF
THIS I CAN THINK OF ONE IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN WHERE THE
TERRORIST GROUP ISIS
ESSENTIALLY USED AMBULANCES FOR
AN ATTACK. AND THEN A TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WHEN THE
AFGHAN TALIBAN- CARRIED OUT A
MAJOR ATTACK USING AMBULANCES
THAT KILLED MORE THAN ONE
HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS SO THESE
ARE SOME OF THE VARIOUS WAYS IN
WHICH- I REALLY WORRY ABOUT
HOW- FIRST RESPONDER EQUIPMENT
CAN BE USED OR HOW FIRST
RESPONDERS. CAN BE TARGETED
SPECIFICALLY. AND IT'S HAPPEN
CAL RIGHT IN OUR STATE HERE AS
WELL I'M BILL OF YOU THAT CAN.
FROM FEBRUARY DESTINY. WHERE
EMTS AND FIRST RESPONDERS- A
FIREFIGHTER IN THE CAN DOWN AND
A PARAMEDIC WERE TARGETED IN
ANTIOCH CALIFORNIA BY A DRIVE
BY SHOOTING DAYS THEY WERE THEY
WERE AMBUSHED AND I THINK THAT
IS A REAL EXAMPLE- IN OUR
BACKYARD OF THESE KINDS OF
TACTICS USING BEING USED IN
THIS CASE. BY INDIVIDUALS MAY
NOT NECESSARILY BEEN PART OF A
FOREIGN TERRORIST ORGANIZATION
BUT INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE ENGAGED
IN CRIMINALITY. BUT WE ALSO
CAN'T FORGET ABOUT THE THREAT
POSED BY GROUPS BASED OVERSEAS-
AND HOW THEY CAN STILL INSPIRE
INDIVIDUALS TO DO REAL WORLD
HARM. IN THIS SENSE- THE STATE
OF NEW JERSEY ISSUED REALLY
IMPORTANT GUIDANCE IN APRIL
TWENTY TWENTY ONE JUST LAST
MONTH. ABOUT HOW INDIVIDUALS
WHO MAY BE INSPIRED BY GROUPS
LIKE AL QAEDA IN THE ISLAMIC
STATE- ARE STILL MOTIVATING
INDIVIDUALS TO CARRY OUT-
AMBUSH LIKE STYLE ATTACKS IN
HERE YOU HAVE A- SPECIFIC
EXAMPLE I HAVE ON THIS POWER
POINT SCREEN. OF AN INDIVIDUAL
BY THE END OF THE SEASON SOME
OF WHICH- WHO ATTACK THREE NEW
YORK CITY POLICE OFFICERS WITH
A KNIFE EVEN USING ESSENTIALLY
THE CAMOUFLAGE OF BML PROTEST
TO CARRY OUT THE ATTACK. AND AS
TIME WENT ON WE LEARNED THAT
SOME ADDITION CELL WAS INSPIRED
BY SALAFI JIHADIST PROPAGANDA.
IN IN THE OFFICIAL PUBLICATIONS
OF ORGANIZATIONS LIKE AL QAEDA
IN THE ISLAMIC STATE YOU STILL
SEE- GROUPS LIKE AL QAEDA
CALLING OUT FOR LONE WOLF OR
LOAN OFFENDER ATTACKS AGAINST
LAW ENFORCEMENT IN THIS
SPECIFICALLY USE THAT
CAMOUFLAGE OF PROTEST TO CARRY
OUT THOSE ATTACKS. IN HERE YOU
HAVE AN EXCERPT. FROM
PUBLICATION BY AL QAEDA THAT'S
CALLING ON. INDIVIDUALS TO
CARRY OUT A MOLOTOV COCKTAIL
ATTACKS SO THE DEPARTURE FROM
THE KNIFE ATTACKS FROM THE
PREVIOUS SCREEN- IN POWER POINT
SLIDE BUT THE POINT HERE IS-
THESE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
BEHIND THESE FOREIGN BASED
GROUPS ARE A PERSISTENT THREAT.
TO AMERICANS TODAY I'M IN THE
CONTINUE TO INSPIRE INDIVIDUALS
THAN THE SUM OF ITS ATTACK WAS
JUST LAST YEAR SO WE CAN'T
DISCOUNT THAT. POSSIBILITY OF
THE FOREIGN BASED ON INFLUENCE
THREATS MOVING FORWARD- THE
SECOND THING I WOULD SAY IS- WE
ALSO NEED TO BE MINDFUL OF HOW
FOREIGN BASED GROUPS. CAN USE
TACTICS THAT CAN BE EMULATED BY
DOMESTIC EXTREMISTS MANY OF
THOSE THAT TOM SPOKE ABOUT IN
HIS POWER POINT SLIDE- IN. WHEN
THEY DO THIS WITH GROUPS CARRY
THIS OUT- THESE KINDS OF
ATTACKS GROUPS LIKE HAMAS
GROUPS LIKE HEZBOLLAH HAVE
ACTUALLY MISUSED MEDICAL
FACILITIES- TO ESSENTIALLY USE
THOSE FACILITIES ASK COMMAND
AND CONTROL CENTER SO THEY
COULD STAGE ATTACKS. AGAINST
GOVERNMENTS LIKE ISRAEL- AND
YOU HAVE SOME EXAMPLES HERE IN
THIS POWER POINT SLIDE WHERE I
MENTION A FEW OF THESE IN A OF
COURSE- DIS WOULD GO AGAINST.
INTERNATIONAL LAW- PURSUANT TO
THE GENEVA CONVENTION- MEDICAL
NEUTRALITY ACTUALLY PREVENTS
BAD ACTORS FROM ESSENTIALLY
USING THESE KINDS OF FACILITIES
TO CARRY OUT- TERRORIST ATTACKS
OR ANY KINDS OF TAX IF IT'S
THAT THE STATE AND STATE-
ENGAGEMENTS AT THE- AT THE
STATE LEVEL. I'M OBVIOUSLY
TERRORIST GROUPS DON'T CARE
ABOUT THESE RULES BUT WE STILL.
NEED TO BE COGNIZANT OF THE
FACT THAT THEY HAVE I USED IT
IN THE- AS COVER- CHURCH CORPS-
MEMBERS OF THE ORGAN. BEFORE
THAT THESE KINDS OF TACTICS
COULD ALSO BE DEPLOYED BY
DOMESTIC EXTREMISTS MAY NOT BE
ASSOCIATED WITH GROUPS LIKE
HAMAS. THOSE OF US IN
CALIFORNIA WILL REMEMBER WELL
OF COURSE IN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN SAMPOERNA DINO ATTACK
CARRIED OUT BY A FOR REAL CAN
AND MALIK WHO CARRIED OUT THE
ATTACK AT THE INLAND REGIONAL
CENTER- IN THAT PARTICULAR
ATTACK IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
THE INDIVIDUALS WERE INSPIRED
BY ISIS- THEY CARRIED THAT
ATTACK OUT BECAUSE THEY WERE
INSPIRED BY. THE FOREIGN BASED
ORGANIZATION KNOWN AS THE
ISLAMIC STATE I'M IN THEY
CARRIED AN ATTACK THAT KILLED
FOURTEEN INDIVIDUALS- AND
INJURED TWO POLICE OFFICERS SO
WE HAVE A ANOTHER EXAMPLE IN
CALIFORNIA OF A SCENARIO IN
WHICH A FOREIGN BASED GROUP- IS
INFLUENCING THE ACTIVITIES
INDIVIDUALS BASED IN UNITED
STATES. ANOTHER MORE RECENT
ATTACK AT THE END OF TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN WAS ONE
CARRIED OUT BY. AN INDIVIDUAL
BY THE NAME OF MOHAMMED SAEED
AL SHAMMARI- AND HE WAS AN
INDIVIDUAL. WHO IS IN THE
UNITED STATES ACTUALLY TRAINING
IN HIS OFFICIAL CAPACITY AS
PART OF THE ROYAL SAUDI AIR
FORCE- AT A AIR BASE AND IN
PENSACOLA- IN FLORIDA. IN HE
WAS EVENTUALLY- KNOWN TO HAVE.
LINKS TO AL QAEDA IN THE
ARABIAN PENINSULA AFTER HE
CARRIED OUT HIS DEADLY ATTACKS
ANOTHER EXAMPLE IN WHICH I JUST
WANT TO. REMIND EVERYBODY THAT
THE LINKS BETWEEN BAR GROUPS
AND INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY BE
EITHER ALREADY IN UNITED STATES
THAT CITIZENS. OR WHO ARE
TRAVELLING THE UNITED STATES
AND SOME KIND OF OFFICIAL
CAPACITY THEY STILL POSE A
RISK- BUT TRANSITIONING TO THE
DOMESTIC RISK- IT IS VERY
PRONOUNCED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND- YOU HAVE A
SLIDE- THAT IS A HEAT MAP THAT
ILLUSTRATES IN TWENTY TWENTY
ACCORDING TO THE SOUTHERN
POVERTY LAW CENTER. THE
LOCATIONS IN WHICH HATE GROUPS
ARE BASED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND AS YOU'LL SEE-
OBVIOUSLY- THE FOCUS AREAS ARE
IN VERY- URBAN AREAS IN OUR
POPULATION CENTERS OF LOS
ANGELES AND THE MORE GENERALLY
SPEAKING IN THE SAN FRANCISCO
AREA- ANOTHER REALLY IMPORTANT
COMPONENT OF THE FINDINGS
RELATED THE SOUTHERN POVERTY
LAW CENTER STUDY. WAS THAT
TYPES OF HATE GROUPS BASED ON
THEIR IDEOLOGY AND IN HERE- YOU
SEE ASIDE FROM. THIS GENERAL
MONAKER- A LABEL- OF HATE
ASSOCIATED WITH 30% OF OUR- THE
INCIDENTS THAT THEY IDENTIFIED
YOU SEE WHITE NATIONALISM
WHICH- TOM HAS TALKED ABOUT HIS
PRESENTATION- AND RACIST
SKINHEADS AND NEO **** FORMING
A PRETTY SIGNIFICANT CHUNK OF
THE KINDS OF- IDEOLOGICALLY
MOTIVATED EXTREMISM. IN THE
ACTUAL- CALIFORNIA AREA IN THEM
BASED ON LOCATION- A
SIGNIFICANT CHUNK OF WHICH- IS
BASED IN LOS ANGELES AT
THIRTEEN AND A HALF PERCENT SO
NOT INSIGNIFICANT- PERCENTAGE.
AND THEN IF YOU LOOK AT THE-
MAP HERE THAT YOU SEE IN FRONT
OF USE THAT DELVES INTO
SPECIFIC INCIDENTS BETWEEN
TWENTY AND TWENTY AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- ASSOCIATED WITH
WHITE SUPREMACY RELATED
ACTIVITY. THE ANTI DEFAMATION
LEAGUE FOUND THAT THERE WERE
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY TWO
INCIDENTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THE VAST MAJORITY
OF THEM WERE NONVIOLENT IN
ORIENTATION THEY WERE
PROPAGANDISTIC IN ORIENTATION
THREE HUNDRED FORTY FIVE OUT OF
THAT. THREE HUNDRED FIFTY TWO
AND HERE AGAIN YOU SEE THIS IT
MAPS- A DIFFERENT ORGANS. AND
DEFINITE LEAGUE ALSO- THEIR
FINDINGS. WITH THE SOUTHERN
POVERTY CENTER HEATMAP
REGARDING THEIR LOCATIONS OF
ANTI HATE GROUPS IN CALIFORNIA
IN OUR POPULATION CENTERS IN
SAN FRANCISCO AND LOS ANGELES.
OKAY THE ANTI SEMITISM SEMITISM
IN CALIFORNIA ALSO ADDED THAT
THREE HUNDRED- PLUS CASES.
NEARLY THREE OR FIFTY CASES A
VERY SIGNIFICANT CHUNK OF THOSE
RELATED TO ANTI SEMITIC-
RELATED INCIDENTS ACCORDING TO
THE ANTI DEFAMATION LEAGUE IN
THIS TEND TO BE AN AREA OF
FOCUS OF WHITE SUPREMACIST
GROUPS- AS WELL- IF THERE'S
ANOTHER ORGANIZATION- THAT
PRODUCED A REALLY INTERESTING
HEATMAP AS WELL OF SEARCH
TERMS. WAS TOM WAS TALKING
ABOUT- THIS ON LIKE AN ACTIVITY
IN THE ONLINE WORLD IN WHICH
SOME OF THESE INDIVIDUALS- AND
HABIT- ORGANIZATION BY NAME OF
MOON SHOTS DEVIANT LOOK AT
ESSENTIALLY THE TOP SEARCH
TERMS IN CALIFORNIA- AND SOME
OF THE SEARCH TERMS HERE
RELATED ATTACK HATE ORIENTED
SEARCH TERMS- ARE VERY MUCH
IDENTIFIABLE- WITH NEO **** OR-
WHITE SUPREMACIST ORGANIZATIONS
FOURTEEN WORDS IS ASSOCIATE
WHITE WHITE SUPREMACIST
MOVEMENT. OBVIOUSLY SICK HEIL
AND PHRASES LIKE THAT
ASSOCIATED WITH NEO **** GROUPS
THERE THERE ARE SO MANY TERMS
HERE- SOME OF WHICH WERE JUST
SO TOXIC I HAD TO ACTUALLY
BLOCK OUT- BUT THIS IS AN
EXAMPLE OF- PEOPLE. USING
ONLINE TOOLS TO TRY TO LEARN
MORE ABOUT HATRED IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SPECIFICALLY WE HAVE
A NUMBER OF ORGANIZATIONS THAT
I'M PARTICULARLY CONCERNED
ABOUT ONE GROUP OF THE I'M
KNOWN AS THE RISE ABOVE
MOVEMENT OPERATING IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA HAS CARRIED OUT. A
NUMBER OF MY OWN ACTIVITIES IN
THE STATE- THEY ARE AN
ORGANIZATION THAT WAS FOUNDED
BY AN INDIVIDUAL BY THE NAME OF
ROBERT RUN GO- HE WAS CHARGED
WITH FEDERAL CRIMES IN THOSE
CHARGES. WERE DISMISSED BUT
THEN- HE WAS AGAIN RECENTLY
RECHARGE FOR INVOLVEMENT IN
RIOTS IN ACTUALLY INTERESTING
THING ABOUT RUN THOUGH IS THAT
HE HAS FLED OVERSEAS IN THE
LAST REPORT I SAW IS THAT YOU
MAY BE IN THE BALKANS. AND
EUROPEAN LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
TRYING TO FIND. HIM SO HE CAN
BE SENT BACK TO CAL YEAH SO HE
CAN BE- TRIED THE THING I WOULD
SAY THAT I THINK IS REALLY. AND
IN THE CONTEXT OF OUR
CONVERSATION IS THAT GROUPS
LIKE THE RISE ABOVE MOVEMENT
HAVE LINKAGES OVERSEAS NOT ONLY
IS RUN GO HAS THE FLIGHT
OVERSEAS BUT BEFORE- HE REALLY
BECAME WELL KNOWN HE WAS
TRAVELING TO A TO UKRAINE TO
ASSOCIATE WITH. A EUROPEAN
BASED WHITE SUPREMACIST
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE THE AZOV
BATTALION FOR INSTANCE- WHERE
HE ACTUALLY ENGAGED THEN- BY
CLUBS- IN AN MMA EVENTS WITH
THIS ORGANIZATION. ANOTHER
ORGANIZATION THAT'S REALLY
CLOSE TO HOME- IS THIS GROUP
KNOWN AS THE ATOMWAFFEN
DIVISION IN. A NEO **** BASED
GROUP. WORK ONE MEMBER OF THAT
ORGANIZATION I'M AS YOU SEEN
HERE MURDERED- YEAH CALIFORNIA
ASSISTED BY THE NAME OF BLAZE
BERNSTEINADAM OFTEN DIVISION
CARRIED OUT A NUMBER OF ATTACKS
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND
EIGHTEEN. THROUGHOUT THE UNITED
STATES AND ALSO IS AN
ORGANIZATION THAT HAS OVERSEAS
LINKAGES AS WELL AND IN FACT
HAS SERVED AS THE INSPIRATION
FOR THE CREATION OF A NUMBER
OF- AUTUMN WAFFEN DIVISION
AFFILIATE GROUPS BASED
OVERSEAS- THROUGHOUT EUROPE-
NOW THE BOOGALOO BOYS- TOMHAS.
SPOKEN ABOUT BEFORE SO I'M
GOING TO SKIP OVER THIS LIVE
WERE AYE I MENTION- STEVEN
CARILLO THE ALLEGED MURDER OF A
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT.
OFFICER OAKLAND ALSO CARRIED
OUT A DEADLY ATTACK AGAINST. A
DEPUTY SHERIFF IN SANTA CRUZ
NOT FAR FROM FROM WHERE I LIVE-
THAT IMPORTANT THING I THINK
THE EMPHASIZING JUST UNDERSCORE
WHAT TOM HAD SAID HERE IS THAT
OF ALL THE GROUPS I AM ACTUALLY
PERSONALLY CONCERNED ABOUT IT'S
THE ANTI GOVERNMENT GROUPS LIKE
THE BLUE BLAZE- AS THEY POSE A
THREAT DIRECTLY TO. THOSE WHO
ARE WORKING FOR STATE FEDERAL
OR LOCAL GOVERNMENTAL OFFICES
THEY ARE I'M ANTI POLICE FOR
INSTANCE TO THE CORE- AND
THEY'RE ALSO- IN THE SLIGHTEST
SPEAKS ABOUT SOME OF THE WAYS
IN WHICH- CORREOS ACTIVITIES
WERE IDENTIFIED. LARGELY
THROUGH HIS COMMUNICATION OVER
SOCIAL MEDIA WHICH IS AGAIN TO
UNDERSCORE A POINT TOM HAD MADE
BUT ALSO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO MENTION- THAT CAREER DID NOT
OPERATE IN ISOLATION- HE HAS
BEEN NOW SINCE LINKS TO A GROUP
CALLED THE GRISLY SCOUTS WHICH
IS A CALIFORNIA BASED MILITIA
GROUP BASED AN- INTERLOCAL
FORTY ABOUT A HUNDRED MILES
FROM SAN FRANCISCO- AND THERE
HAVE BEEN SOME. ARRESTS OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO WORK-
ASSOCIATED WITH CARILLO- AS
RECENTLY AS LAST LAST MONTH BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE SO
AGAIN- THE THREAT POSED BY
INDIVIDUALS LIKE CARILLO- HAS
HAS NOT WANED- WE'RE STILL
FINDING INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
PART OF THIS ANTI GOVERNMENT
MILIEU WHO. POSE A THREAT TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. NOW IN
TERMS OF PAUL RECOMMENDATIONS-
ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT.
RECOMMENDATIONS I THINK I COULD
PROVIDE- TO YOU IS AND I THINK
THIS UNDERSCORES AGAIN TOM'S
POINT. THE NEED TO CONSIDER
USING- ADDITIONAL MEASURES TO-
SURVEIL AS APPROPRIATE AND
PURSUANT TO THE LAW INDIVIDUALS
ASSOCIATED WITH SOME OF THE
TYPES OF GROUPS I DESCRIBED
TODAY- IT IF YOU GO BACK TO
SOME OF THOSE EARLIER MAPS IN
TERMS OF THE NUMBER OF TROOPS
THAT WE NEED TO BE CONCERNED
ABOUT- IT IS A- SIGNIFICANT.
CHALLENGE BUT ONE
RECOMMENDATION THAT MAY BE
PRACTICAL IS ALSO CONSIDERING-
THE EXPANSION OF THE HERTZBERG-
OUR TIME CALIFORNIA PREVENTION
TERRORISM ACT- JUST AS TOM
DESCRIBED THE FACT THAT. IN THE
UNITED STATES WE DON'T HAVE A
DOMESTIC TERRORISM STATUTE
FEDERALLY A LOT OF STATES DON'T
HAVE SUFFICIENT LAWS TO TACKLE
THE THREAT DOMESTIC TERRORISM.
CALIFORNIA'S BETTER THE MANY-
BUT STILL CAN DO BETTER. REALLY
I WOULD BRING YOUR ATTENTION TO
THIS SECOND BULLET POINTS HERE-
WHERE THE LAW AS IT EXISTS
TODAY ONLY PROHIBITS THE USE OF
THE THREATS. OR USE OF WEAPONS
OF MASS DESTRUCTION- WHICH CAN
INCLUDE INCENDIARY DEVICES SO
IT IS PRETTY NARROW IT WOULDN'T
COVER- ACTS OF VIOLENCE RELATED
TO TERRORISM- THAT MAY FOR
INSTANCE USE SMALL ARMS AND I
SEE THAT AS A GAP THAT COULD BE
LEGISLATIVE REALLY REMEDY- THE
LAST THING I'LL SAY- IS. I DO
BELIEVE- EMERGENCY RESPONDERS
FIREFIGHTERS EMTS LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT REMAIN AT HIGH RISK
OF AMBUSH ATTACKS THEY REALLY
DO NEED ADDITIONAL TRAINING BY
THE STATE AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT SO THEY CAN BE
BETTER PREPARED IF THEY ARE PUT
IN A SITUATION WHERE THEY COULD
FACE. AN AMBUSH ATTACK AND I
THINK ONE WAY TO DO THIS COULD
BE A MANDATORY REQUIREMENTS TO
PROVIDE EMERGENCY RESPONDERS
AND REQUEST EMERGENCY
RESPONDERS TO WEAR TACTICAL
DEFENSE GEAR. AT LEAST IN VERY
SPECIFIC KINDS OF SITUATIONS
AND PLACES LIKE LAKELAND
FLORIDA- YOU HAVE SEEN WHERE
YOU HAVE. THAT THANKFULLY
THOSE. FIREFIGHTERS IN LAKELAND
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO PURCHASE FOR
INSTANCE SIXTEEN BALLISTIC
VESTS- THROUGH A FIREHOUSE SUBS
PUBLIC SAFETY FOUNDATION BRAND
I THINK THAT THAT GOES A LONG
WAY TO PROTECTING. OUR
EMERGENCY RESPONDERS AND THOSE
WHO ARE ARE ON THE FRONT LINES
OF KEEPING US SAFE- I'LL SKIP
OVER THESE LAST FEW FLIGHTS
BECAUSE I WANT TO HAVE TIME
FOR. FOR QUESTIONS I'LL JUST
END BY SAYING THAT- I PROVIDED
THE POWER POINT TO YOUR STAFF
MEMBERS AND I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
SHARE- THIS VERSION THAT ALSO
INCLUDES CITATIONS THAT MAY BE
HELPFUL AND WITH THAT I'LL
POLICY. HERE AND- WOULD LOVE TO
HEAR YOUR YOUR QUESTIONS. WELL
THANK YOU ARE. THANK YOU TO FOR
YOU TESTING PART. NOW WILL IT
UP BACK TO. THE COMMITTEE FOR
PROBABLY SOME QUESTION BY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ONE THING I
JUST WANTED A- REALLY- THANK
YOU FOR THAT LAST PART OF
PARTICIPATION REGARDING OR- A
REGARDING THE YOU USE THE
BALLISTIC GEAR FOR FIRST
RESPONDERS OUT SO. VERY
CRITICAL NOWADAYS- MORE THAN
EVER THEY NOT ONLY MYSELF BUT
VICE CHAIR KELLY CAN TALK ABOUT
THE NEED FOR THAT BEING WHERE
WE CAME FROM AND- EMS AND-
DEALING WITH A LOT OF ISSUES
OUT THERE IN IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. ALSO WITHOUT SAID-
WE TALKED ABOUT THE USE OF
SOCIAL MEDIA ON THE INTERNET.
ATTORNEY UNIQUE THREE THREATS
TO CALIFORNIA REGARDING THAT
AND IF SO WHAT ARE WE DOING TO
ADDRESS THOSE ISSUES. SO I
WOULD BE HAPPY TO TAKE THE
FIRST STAB AT AT THIS
PARTICULAR QUESTION AND ONE OF
THE ROLES I HAVE AT THE
MIDDLEBURY INSTITUTE OF
INTERNATIONAL STUDIES AT THAT
CENTER ON TEARS OF EXTREMISM
AND COUNTERTERRORISM FOR US IS
TO. PARTNER WITH SILICON VALLEY
COMPANIES- TO PROVIDE THEM
ASSISTANCE REGARDING WAYS IN
WHICH EXTREMISTS ARE USING
THEIR PLATFORMS. TO PROPAGATE
MESSAGES RELATED TO HATE AND
SPECIFICALLY IDENTIFY- MATERIAL
THAT MAY VIOLATE THEIR
COMMUNITY AND SAFETY GUIDELINES
AND MATERIAL THAT. MAY WELL
ACTUALLY- TARGET SPECIFIC
INDIVIDUALS FOR ACTS OF
VIOLENCE IN IN TARGETING
SPECIFIC PROTECTIVE FEDERAL
GROUPS AS WELL. AND IN THIS
SENSE- I THINK. MOST OF US
WOULD AGREE I THINK THAT
SILICON VALLEY- COMPANIES
WHETHER IT'S- FACEBOOK TWITTER.
GOOGLE YOUTUBE ALL OF THEM CAN
STILL DO MUCH BETTER IN THE
CONTEXT OF ENSURING THAT THEIR
PLATFORMS ARE ABUSED BY. BAD
ACTORS IN THERE HAVE BEEN
REPORTS OVER TIME GOOD PRESS
REPORTS ABOUT HOW IN FACT.
ALGORITHMS HAVE BEEN USED TO
RECOMMEND- A NEW FACEBOOK PAGE
TO FOLLOW A NEW- YOUTUBE VIDEO
TO WATCH I'M A NEW PERSON TO
FOLLOW OVER TWITTER. THAT COULD
LEAD ONE DOWN THE RABBIT HOLE
OF RADICALIZATION SO. ONE THING
I THINK THAT COULD BE USEFUL-
IS TO CONTINUE TO EVALUATE HOW
ALGORITHMS MAY BE USED BY
SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES TO
INFLAME INDIVIDUALS TO
RADICALIZE INDIVIDUALS. AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DOES HAVE
ONE BILL THAT'S BEEN
INTRODUCED- TO TRY TO DO BETTER
IN TERMS OF THAT. CONCEPT OF
ALGORITHMIC RADICALIZATION THAT
IS A THREAT BUT I ALSO THINK
THE STATE HAS A ROLE TO PLAY AS
WELL. IN ENSURING THAT THESE-
AT LARGE TECH COMPANIES DO DO
THEIR PART IN ENSURING THAT THE
PLATFORMS. ARE BEING ABUSED BY
A BAD ACTOR SO I DO THE ISSUE
OF ALGAL. IS A REALLY IMPORTANT
WHAT. HI THANK YOU- ANY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT FROM. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLERIA QUESTION. FROM YOU
HAVE A COUPLE QUESTIONS SO. DO
WE DO WE NEED TO MAKE SOME KIND
OF DISTINCTION BETWEEN WHAT
MIGHT BE. FRINGE VIEWPOINTS IN
SOCIETY. AND DOMESTIC
TERRORISM- AND ALL AND ALL OF.
YEAH I MEAN THEY SEEM TO BE A
BIG FOCUS ON FOR EXAMPLE LIKE
Q. ANON RIGHT WHICH IS.
CERTAINLY A CONSPIRACY THEORY.
YOU KNOW- THE GOES AROUND TO
DIFFERENT GROUPS BUT ISN'T
NECESSARILY LINKED TO ANY KIND
OF DOMESTIC TERRORISM IN
ITSELF- AND JUST LIKE I MEAN
FOR INSTANCE I'LL DO ANOTHER
KNOWLEDGE I MEAN A LOT OF
PEOPLE OF ISLAMIC FAITH BUT WE
CERTAINLY DON'T. A TRIBUTE ALL
OF THEM TO THE FUNDAMENTALISTS
WHO MIGHT CARRY OUT TERRORIST
ATTACKS LIKE IN SAND SAMPOERNA
DINO- MY NAME IF YOU WILL HAVE
VERY FUNDAMENTALIST RELIGIOUS
VIEWS. BUT THAT DOESN'T
NECESSARILY LEAD TO ARE NOT
ENGAGING IN VIOLENCE- OR IN
CARRYING OUT ATTACKS- EVEN OUT
THIS SUMMER- YOU KNOW A LOT OF.
PROTESTS REGARDING THE- MURDER
OF GEORGE FLOYD- AND I THINK
WHAT A LOT OF PEOPLE SALAS A CO
OPTION OF SOME OF THE VERY
PEACEFUL PROTEST FOR THE MOST
PART. BY MORE FRINGE GROUPS- I.
YOU KNOW THAT CARRIED OUT
ATTACKS BATTERIES TWO PEOPLE
WERE KILLED- DURING SOME OF
THOSE PROTESTS NATIONWIDE- IS
THERE A DISTINCTION THERE AND
MAYBE TO THAT SPECIFIC QUESTION
THIS SUMMER DO I DIDN'T HEAR
MUCH ON THIS POINT BUT- I
BELIEVE WAS MR O'CONNOR POINTED
OUT THERE'S THE UNDER THE
CAMOUFLAGE OF PROTEST. SOME OF
THESE GROUPS ARE KIND OF
INFILTRATING PROTESTS AND
CARRYING OUT- YOU KNOW
TERRORIST ATTACKS. DO WE FIND
OUT THAT THERE WERE SOME GROUPS
INVOLVED WITH SAY EXAMPLE THAT
THE PROTEST WE SAW THIS SUMMER
WHERE I THINK FROM A LOT OF THE
MEDIA REPORTS. VERY MUCH
PEACEFUL PROTEST OBVIOUSLY
PEOPLE FRUSTRATED AND ANGRY.
BUT WE'RE NOT CARRYING OUT ANY
KIND OF ATTACKS BUT THEN THERE
WERE OBVIOUSLY GROUPS IN THERE
THAT WERE IN FACT DOING THAT-
DID WE FIND OUT THAT THERE WERE
CERTAIN GROUPS RESPONSIBLE. OR
THEY WERE HELPING ORGANIZE THAT-
BECAUSE I THINK THERE IS KIND
OF A DISTINCTION AND WE TEND TO
KIND OF HIT THESE THINGS WITH A
BROAD BRUSH. AND THAT CAN BE.
PROBLEMATIC I THINK MEANS SO
MAYBE JUST SPEAK TO THAT ISSUE.
IF I IF I CAN JUMP BY
MEDITATION- I APPRECIATE THAT
QUESTION BECAUSE IT IS SPOT ON
RIGHT- IN THE BEGINNING OF THE
POWER POINT PRESENTATION I TALK
ABOUT THE FIRST AMENDMENT AND
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE FIRST
AMENDMENT HOW THE FIRST MOMENT
WINS OUT IN IN- ANY DISCUSSIONS
WITH THE AND WHEN IT COMES TO
INVESTIGATIONS- SO IT IT IT IS
NOT THE- ACTIVITY THAT THE
PROTEST AS YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
THAT DRAWS INVESTIGATION. INTO
THE VIOLENCE AND THAT IS- IF
THAT IS THE EXTREME VIOLENCE
RIGHT SO WE'RE TALKING WHEN I
MENTIONED- UNDER THE COVER OF
THE PROTESTS THAT WAS IN
REGARDS TO THE BOOGALOO BOYS
WHO KILLED A FEDERAL PROTECTIVE
OFFICER AT THE OAKLAND
COURTHOUSE- JUST A SHORT
DISTANCE AWAY FROM A BLACK
LIVES MATTER RALLY. IN THEIR
INTENT WAS TO BLAME THAT
KILLING AND THE BLACK LIVES
MATTER GROUP THAT WAS THERE
THERE IT'S SOLE PURPOSE WITH IT
TO MAKE IT LOOK LIKE THAT'S HOW
WITH A WHO WAS DONE BY- SO
UNDER THE COVER OF PROTESTS
THEY USED A- A MURDER- TO TRY
AND- PUT IT BACK ON AND- THE
OTHER PEOPLE- SO IT TRULY IS
THE VIOLENT ACTIONS AS YOU
SAID. Q. ANON HAS HAD- I MEAN
IT'S A CONSPIRACY THEORY
THERE'S THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE TO
FOLLOW IT IF THE PEOPLE WHO
WILL SHOW UP IN WASHINGTON DC
AND FIRE OFF A RIFLE INSIDE A
COMET PIZZA BECAUSE THEY
BELIEVE THE CONSPIRACY THEORY
THAT THERE ARE CHILDREN BEING
HELD IN THE BASEMENT THERE BY.
DEMOCRATS AND- YOU KNOW WOULD
BE PARTICULARLY- HILLARY
CLINTON AND- PROTEST- IN THEIR
EMAILS THEY THAT THEY CO NO.
QUIETLY SAID THAT THERE WERE
CHILDREN IN THE BAY PLACE THE-
THEORIES IN THE QUEUE DRAW WILL
THIS TO DRIVE FROM. UP TO ONE
THE FIRE OFF A GUN. OF THE- COM
PIZZA SO THERE HAVE- THE VINYL
IS WHY NEEDS TO BE. LOOKED THAT-
IT'S NOT THE IDEA. IT NOT THE-
THEORY- THOSE ARE THINGS THAT
CAN. TO A- BUT I STATED IT THE
VIOLENCE THE LAW ENFORCED NEED
TO LOOK AT- A IN YOUR CAN HAVE.
DIFFERENT YOU. HOLD CAN.
THEORIES AND THAT'S FINE IT'S
YOU USE THAT- STEP OUT INTO BY.
BETTER BECAUSE- A LAW ENFORCED
ISSUE YEAH THAT THAT WAS ALL OF
THE- I THINK YOU SAID THE
ACTUALLY AL-QAEDA'S IN. ISLAMIC
STATE HAVE SAID IN THEIR- IN A
LOT OF THEIR STUFF- ONLINE-
PROPAGANDA THAT THEY ARE USING.
THE CAMOUFLAGE OF PROTEST. AS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO THESE
THINGS AND I WOULD ALSO SAY
ISN'T THIS A COMMON TACTIC ALSO
OF ANTIFA. TO USE THE
CAMOUFLAGE OF PROTEST TO DO
EXACTLY THE THINGS YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT. SO PUBLISHER OF
THE JASON BECAUSE I DIDN'T
MENTION ALL KIND OF OR- OKAY
MAYBE THAT WE CHASE AND SARIA.
IT WAS ONE OF THE TWO BALD GUYS
SO- THAT WAS THAT WAS
DEFINITELY ME- AND ACTUALLY IN
THE PUBLICATIONS THEY DO
ENCOURAGE- INDIVIDUALS WHO MAY
BE SUPPORT OF THE AL QAEDA OR
ISIS MESSAGE. TO LEVERAGE
PROTESTS AND IT LEVERAGING
PROTEST WHETHER IT'S LEFT WING
RIGHT WING OF RELIGIOUSLY
MOTIVATED TERRORIST YOU'RE
ALWAYS GOING TO HAVE BAD ACTORS
WHO MAY BE- SEEING THAT
PROTESTS THAT COULD BE A
LEGITIMATE PROTESTS- A WHEN TOM
HAD THE SLIGHT ABOUT PEOPLE
YELLING AND- AND RAISING YOUR
VOICES TO PROTEST THAT'S
COMPLETELY. UNACCEPTABLE THIS
IS THE UNITED STATES BUT THERE
ARE THOSE INDIVIDUALS OUT THERE
AND IT DOESN'T MATTER THE KIND
OF GROUP- IT DATE THANK YOU
WANT TO INFILTRATE AND TOM.
REFERENCED A LOCAL- THE
BILLABLE A RELATED ATTACK IN
AND THAT WAS A ONE AT THAT I
THINK CAN US ALL CLOSED AT THE
HOME BECAUSE THAT WAS HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT ONE
OF. THE OTHER ONES I REMEMBER
VERY VIVIDLY I AM NOT LONG
BEFORE THAT WAS IN IN VEGAS-
AND ANOTHER BML BLM PROTESTS-
IN WHICH A FEDERAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT INTERCEPTED TWO ARE
ACTUALLY THREE MEMBERS OF THE
BLUE BOYS WHO ARE PLAYING- AND
ATTACK THEIR ALSO TOOK TO USE
MOLOTOV. COCKTAILS AND THEN WE
DOOFFER CALL IN THE PACIFIC
NORTHWEST- SO THE WITH THE
FIRST I THINK THAT'S A
TYPICALLY- IT SHOULD BE A BIT-
TRIBBLE GAP TO AN INDIVIDUAL
WHO SELF IDENTIFY AS- ANTIFA
CARRIED OUT- A SHOOTING AT A
PROTEST- KILLING A MEMBER. OF
IN A ORGANIZATION I THINK WITH
COMPATRIOT FIRST OR SOMETHING
LIKE THAT SO- THAT WAS A- A
LEFT WING- INCIDENTS THAT I CAN
RECALL AS WELL SO. I AM MY
POINT IS IT DOESN'T MATTER- THE
IDEOLOGY YOU'LL FIND BAD ACTORS
WHO ARE GOING TO BE PRONE TO
VIOLENCE TRYING TO LEVERAGE
THESE PROTESTS. TO FURTHER
THEIR OWN AGENDA WHICH IS QUITE
OFTEN VERY. SEPARATE FROM THE
ACTUAL PROTEST ITSELF. YOU CAN
IN MY LIFE QUESTION OR OF. WE
ARE STILL SITTING THE STATE.
AND OUR CAPITAL IS BARRICADED
OFF TO THIS DAY- SINCE THE
NATIONAL THREAT- THAT WAS
THOUGHT TO BE ON THE STATE
CAPITAL I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
GUYS ARE FAMILIAR WITH THIS BUT
ASK YOU TO SPEAK WITH IT. IF
YOU HAVE KNOWLEDGE ABOUT IT
WHAT WAS THE ULTIMATE THREAT-
TO THE STATE CAPITOL THAT
WARRANTED. NATIONAL GUARD BEING
BROUGHT IN- THE BARRICADES THAT
ARE STILL UP- TO THIS DAY. IS
THERE IS THERE ANY EXISTING
THREAT AND WHAT WAS THE ACTUAL
THREAT LEADING UP TO. THE DAY
THAT WE YOU KNOW HAD THESE
BARRICADES AND HAD. NATIONAL
GUARD HERE. YOU EVER TO
ASCERTAIN. WHAT GROUPS WERE
ACTUALLY GOING TO DO ANYTHING.
ON THAT DAY AND WHO ACT AND
MAYBE WHO ACTUALLY DID ANYTHING.
ON ON THAT DATE THAT WE THAT WE
ARE SORT OF BARRICADED UP FOR.
HI I GUESS I CAN JUMP ON THE
FIRST PART OF THAT- SO THE
INTELLIGENCE- THAT WAS-
GATHERED AND PUBLICLY- TALK
ABOUT WAS- A KIND OF A GENERAL
TO- STATE CAPITALS NOT
SPECIFICALLY CALIFORNIA'S STATE
CAPITAL BUT K. STATE CAPITALS
AND A FOLLOW ON. AS THE U. S.
CAPITOL HAVE BEEN LOCKED DOWN
THAT THE- THE CHATTER ONLINE
WAS TO GO TO THE STATE CAPITOL-
THIS LAST- SECURED- YOU KNOW
THEN THE U. S. CAPITOL WAS AT
THE TIME AND IS- SO THAT THAT
WAS THE THREAT- YEAH I RETIRED
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN- FROM
THE F. B. I. SO I DON'T HAVE
THE- THE DAILY BRIEFINGS ON
WHAT THE THREAT WAS- IT
CURRENTLY IS NOW AND I WOULDN'T
VENTURE TO WHAT. TO SAY. OR
WHAT IT WAS GONNA BE- AMERICA
TO MAKE SOME UP FOR YOU. OKAY
I'M- OKAY I THINK UN VICE CHAIR
KELLY SAID A QUESTION I IF YOU
BOTH OF- YOU FOR YOUR UPDATE ON
THAT. YEAH THIS ISSUE HAS BEEN
GOING ON A LONG TIME THAT'S
BEEN GOING ON EVER SINCE I WAS
THE FIRST INTO THE FIRE SERVICE
THIRTY FIVE NOW FORTY YEARS
AGO. AND IT JUST SEEMS THAT ONE
GROUP DISAPPEARS IN ANOTHER
GROUP TAKES ITS PLACE AND I
THINK THE MOST EFFECTIVE THING
THAT HAS BEEN DONE OVER THE
YEARS IS TO FOR THE MOST PART-
KEEP THE GENIES IN THE BOTTLE
AND NOT LET THEM OUT AND EAT
OUT NOW WE HAVE. MORE OF A
PROLIFERATION OF YOU KNOW
BASICALLY PUTTING IT OUT THERE
AND MAKING IT. THIS THAT THESE
PEOPLE GET PUBLICITY. AND THAT
PUBLICITY IS SOMETHING THAT
THEY FEED ON. AND YEAH YOU KNOW
I THINK THE EFFORTS USED TO BE
HEY. YOU KNOW WE WORK QUIETLY
BEHIND THE SCENES TO KEEP THEM
IN THE BOTTLE. AND NW
EVERYBODY WANTS TO HAVE IT OUT
AND I THINK WITH WITH OUR
SOCIAL MEDIA AND THINGS LIKE
THAT THAT'S WHAT'S HAPPENING.
FROM A PUBLIC POLICY
PERSPECTIVE. IT YOU KNOW HOW DO
WE HOW DO WE GO ABOUT DOING
THAT KEEP IN THAT. YOU KNOW
KEEP IT WOULD GET YOU'RE NOT
GOING TO. YOU CAN'T FIX SOME OF
THESE MINDS OF PEOPLE WHO HATE.
BUT YOU CAN CERTAINLY KEEP THEM-
DISCOURAGED FROM ACTING OUT ON
IT. AND THAT'S WHAT I THINK THE
BIG THE BIG POLICY ISSUES ARE
IS HOW DO WE HOW DO WE- GOVERN
SO THAT. YOU KNOW PEOPLE DON'T.
AREN'T ENCOURAGED TO ACT OUT.
BECAUSE WE SEEM TO BE HAVING A
LOT OF THAT. J. SURVIVING JUMP
AND JUST QUICKLY- AND THEN
PASSED OFF TO YOU ON THIS ONE-
THE JOINT TERRORISM TASK FORCES
THAT ARE SET UP ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES FIFTY SIX FIELD
OFFICES ALL HAVE JOINT
TERRORISM TASK FORCES. THEY'RE
MADE UP OF STATE LOCAL AND
EDERAL AGENCIES- THEY ARE
WORKING DAY AND NIGHT- PUTTING
DOWN THREATS THAT ARE COMING IN
AT A AT A RATE WHICH WOULD BE
ALARMING FOR ANYONE WHO WAS NOT
IN THAT- IN THAT MISSION SETS
SO- THEY ARE DOING BE QUIET
WORK BEHIND THE SCENES- TO. TO
TAKE DOWN THESE INDIVIDUAL
ACTORS GET IN FRONT OF THE
VIOLENCE AND YOU DON'T ALWAYS
SEE ABOUT IT YOU DON'T ALWAYS
HEAR ABOUT IT- I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT WHEN WE DO HAVE AN
ACTUAL. EVENT THAT TAKES PLACE
THAT- THAT THE PERSON'S THE
PERSONS WHO ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
THOSE CRIMINAL ACTIVITIES WHICH
MEET THE DEFINITION OF DOMESTIC
TERRORISM I THINK IT WOULD IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR THE VICTIMS- THAT
THESE PEOPLE ARE NOT JUST
CALLED DOMESTIC TERRORISTS BUT
THEY'RE ACTUALLY HAVE THE
ABILITY TO CHARGE THEM
FEDERALLY AS DOMESTIC
TERRORISTS- AND THAT WOULD BE
ADDING IT A PENALTY TO THAT
PAIN- MUCH LIKE. THE HATE
CRIMES- HATE CRIMES HAVE HAVE
THE ABILITY- IF AN EVENT TAKES
PLACE THAT FEELS THE DEFINITION
OF A HATE CRIME IT ALSO
FULFILLS ASSAULTS AND HOMICIDES
THESE TYPE OF THINGS BUT WE
CALL THEM HATE CRIMES WE CHARGE
THEM AND HATE CRIMES BECAUSE
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT. AND ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT THAT'LL DO IS
LET THE VICTIMS THE VICTIMS
FAMILIES KNOW THAT THE
GOVERNMENT IS TAKING THAT
SERIOUSLY- IT IS NOT JUST
VIOLENCE IS VIOLENCE FOR A
POLITICAL PURPOSE. IN IN THE
UNITED STATES THAT'S SOMETHING
WE REALLY CAN'T TOLERATE SO WE
HAVE AN EVENT THAT MEETS THAT
DEFINITION I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE- HAVE THE
ABILITY TO RAISE TWO THAT I
THINK- TO THE CHARGE THAT
PERSON WITH THAT- SO WE CAN
TRACK IT BECAUSE IF YOU LOOK AT
INTERNATIONAL TERRORISM. YOU
CAN LOOK DOWN THE LIST. THAT I
JUST GO ONLINE AND FIND THE NO
BROKE INTERNET TERROR EVENTS
HAVE TAKEN TONIGHT. IF YOU LOOK
UP. TERRORISM YOUR NOT GOING
TO. A AND- LIST AT ALL BECAUSE-
YOU HAVE TO LOOK UP EVERY
ASSAULT EVERY HOMICIDE NC BACK
TO MY PRESENTATION IF THAT
NUMBER TWO WHAT IS THE PURPOSE
WHY DID THIS PERSON DO THIS TO
INTIMIDATE OR COERCE A CIVILIAN
POPULATION. OR TO INFLUENCE THE
POLICY OF THE GOVERNMENT. SO I
BELIEVE THAT WE SHOULD BE
MAKING MARTYRS OUT OF PEOPLE-
FOUR FOUR CASES THAT THAT DON'T
REALLY RISE TO THAT-
DEFINITION. BUT WHEN IT DOES WE
NEED TO TAKE IT SERIOUSLY AND
THAT EVEN OF ITSELF CAN ALSO
NOT ONLY WILL IT HELP TRACK.
WOULD HELP THE VICTIMS AND
THEIR FAMILIES BUT IT WILL
ALSO. BE A DETERRENT- YOU YOU
MAY NOT SPEED DOWN THE HIGHWAY
BECAUSE YOU KNOW YOU'RE GOING
TO GET A TICKET FOR GOING OVER
THAT SPEED LIMIT- PEOPLE MAY
NOT STEP OUT INTO THAT VIOLENCE
IF THEY KNOW THAT THE
GOVERNMENT IS TAKING IT
SERIOUSLY. LIKE WE DO MANY
OTHER ARE CRIMINAL VIOLATIONS.
RIGHT SO WHAT I'M HEARING FROM
YOU ON THIS IS WE NEED TO
CONTINUE. TO ENSURE THAT THE
AGENCIES. CONTINUE TO BE ABLE
TO DO THEIR JOB AND HAVE THE
RESOURCES. AND THE TO DO THAT
JOB. 101% AND- YOU RECENTLY
SAW- THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
UNITED STATES COME OUT AND ASK
FOR FORTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE F. B. I.'S DOMESTIC
TERRORISM- INVESTIGATIONS AND
ANOTHER FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THE U. S. ATTORNEY'S OFFICE
TO PROSECUTE THE INCREASE IN
DOMESTIC TERRORISM CASES WHICH
WE'VE SEEN OVERALL- BEFORE
JANUARY SIX- THE JOINT
TERRORISM TASK FORCES IS THE
CONDUIT FOR STATE AND LOCAL
AGENCIES TO WORK
COUNTERTERRORISM. I PERSONALLY.
NO BECAUSE I WORKED ON A JOINT
TERRORISM TASK FORCE FOR TWENTY
THREE YEARS THAT THAT REALLY IS
A SYSTEM THAT WORKS INVOLVING
SMALL AGENCIES LARGER LOCAL
AGENCIES STATE AGENCIES FBI
AGENTS UGH I MAY SHOW UP IN TO-
LOS ANGELES I DON'T KNOW LOS
ANGELES THE POLICE OFFICERS
THERE TO THE STATE OFFICERS DO
WORKING HAND IN HAND. TO FIGHT
A DOMESTIC AND INTERNATIONAL
TERRORISM IS THE ONLY WAY IT
WORKS IT IS A JOINT OPERATION
AND IN THAT IT NEEDS TO BE
SUPPORTED- AND- AND HAVE THE-
TOOLS NECESSARY TO DO THAT ONE
OF THOSE WOULD BE A PENALTY
ATTACHED TO THE ACTUAL
DEFINITION OF DOMESTIC
TERRORISM RIGHT ANY OTHER ONE I
HEARD WAS THE DETERRENCE. WE
NEED TO CONTINUE TO DETER NOT
REWARD- FOR THAT TYPE OF
BEHAVIOR TO IN ORDER TO
DISCOURAGE IT SO THAT'S ALL I
HAVE. FOR YOU GUYS THANK YOU SO
MUCH APPRECIATED. THANK YOU I
KNOW I THINK WE HAVE SUMMER I'M
OF. CALLED IN NORTH HADN'T
QUITE BEFORE ON TO THE SECOND
POWER. MISTER CHAIR CAN YOU
HEAR ME. OKAY HERE JUST IN AWE
CERNER IF YOU HAD A QUESTION
BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
TOWN I DID. JUST TAKE JUST A
QUICK ONE I KNOW YOU WANT TO
MOVE ON HERE BUT CAN I JUST
THANK YOU FIRST FOR HOLDING
THIS HEARING IN ALLOWING ME TO
BE INCLUDED ALONG WITH I THINK
MY COLLEAGUES FROM. ORANGE
COUNTY CENTER- BURKE WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITTEES
ATTEND TO THE ISSUE- I JUST
WANTED TO I WANTED TO YEP ONE
QUESTION WITH YOUR PANEL HERE
IF THAT'S ALRIGHT MR CHER. YES
THAT'S FINE BUT- OKAY- REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OVERVIEW- WE
DIDN'T REALLY TOUCH OUR WEEK
YOUR RETIREMENT PENALTIES
RETIREMENT DETERRENCE- I DON'T.
QUESTIONS BUT JUST OVERALL
CAPACITY. THE JOINT TERRORISM
TASK FORCE THAT YOU ARE
MENTIONED WAS SUCCESSFUL IN
DISRUPTING- THAT- A TERRORIST
PLOT- FROM A CONSTITUENT OF
MINE IN RECEIPT OF. A FORMER
INFANTRYMAN MARC STEVEN TO MAKE
GO BACK IN TWENTY NINETEEN WHO
CAME BACK FROM AFGHANISTAN IN
COMBAT AND- THANKS TO THE WORK
IN COORDINATION BETWEEN THE
FBI. AND LAPD LA SHERIFF'S-
LONG BEACH PD- AS WELL AS ADAM
OUR STATE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES IF YOU WERE ABLE TO
GET- A CONFIDENTIAL- I FORGET
THERE'S A CHARM CHS I THINK BUT
IT'S A- BAIT AND- UNDER COVER
SOMEONE WAS ABLE TO IT TO GET
TO THIS PERSON AND SUPPLY THEM
WITH THE INERT HE D. THAT THEY
WERE GOING TO BE USING TO BLOW
UP A FREEWAY. AS WELL AS A
APPROACH AT A RALLY OUTSIDE OF
A DEMOCRATIC MEMBER OF CONGRESS
IS OFFICE- YOU KNOW AND WE- WE
WEREN'T THAT SUCCESSFUL. IN A
FEW INCIDENTS. I LOST. A FRIEND
IN POWAY- AND- WE AT THE
BORDERLINE SHOOTING IN MY
DISTRICT TO WHERE TWELVE PEOPLE
WERE KILLED IN A COUNTRY MUSIC
FAR. FROM THE- THE VETERAN WHO
WOULD. HANDLE A LOT OF TRAUMA
AND- A LOT OF WARNING SIGNS IN
FIFTY ONE FIFTIES THAT'D BEEN
SORT OF RECYCLE THAT THROUGH
THE SYSTEM I MEAN KEPT COMING
BACK. BUT I. I MENTIONED YOU
KNOW THAT THE- INTERMINGLE CASE.
BECAUSE IT'S HAPPENING RIGHT IN
OUR DISTRICT- AND RIGHT NOW
COMMUNITIES IN PLACES YOU
WOULDN'T THINK A RECEIPT
CALIFORNIA. KIND OF AMERICANA
MIDDLE CLASS VERY DIVERSE%
COMMUNITY THAT IS TO BE
POSSIBLE- ACTUALLY BABBITT IS
FROM VENTURA COUNTY WAS KILLED
IN THE CAPITAL INCIDENT- AND-
YOU KNOW. I'M MY BIGGEST
CONCERN RIGHT NOW IS CAPACITY I
THINK THE HUMAN INTELLIGENCE
SIDE OF THIS EQUATION IS REALLY
WHAT. WILL MOLLIFY THOSE WHO
MAY BE CONCERNED ON THE RIGHT
OR THE LEFT BACK TO BROAD
BRUSHES ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GALLAGHER POINTED OUT YOU DON'T
WANT TO CAST TOO WIDE OF A NET
OR CRIMINALIZE SPEECH- I
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH THAT AND-
THE ISSUE THOUGH IS THAT IF
THERE. ARE PEOPLE TO CONNECT
THE DOTS WE DON'T OF THE HUMAN
RESOURCES OUT IN THE FIELD TO
DO THIS KIND OF ON THE GROUND
WORK. AND WE'RE NOT LEAVE
OURSELVES VULNERABLE. AND I MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION ACTUALLY CUT
FUNDING TO THE FUSION CENTERS-
OVER THE LAST FOUR YEARS SO
THAT CAPACITY IS NOT WHAT IT
WAS SAY DURING THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION. AND HOMELAND
SECURITY AT THE STATE IS
ACTUALLY TO STEP UP AND CAN
SUBSIDIZE. I'VE BEEN BACK FILL
SOME OF THAT FUNDING. DO YOU DO
YOU SEE A NEED ON THE CAPACITY
SIDE IN ADDITION TO PENALTIES
AND LEGAL CHANGES. TO ACTUALLY
SEE THAT I NEED I THINK THE
STATE FEDERAL OR LOCAL LEVEL
FOR AUGMENTATION- ON THE ON THE
BUDGET SIDE OF THINGS. TO
IMPROVE THIS COORDINATION OR
BUILD CAPACITY I'M I JUST
WONDER IF YOU COULD COMMENT ON
THAT. I'LL I'LL JUMP BY MAGIC
GAME SORRY JASON BUT- BUT
YOU'RE I THINK YOU'RE SPOT ON
ALSO THAT THE JOINT TERRORISM
TASK FORCES OUR WORD IF THAT
REALLY IS WHERE THE RUBBER
MEETS THE ROAD WHERE THE
INVESTIGATIONS ARE DONE. IN
YOUR DISTRICT IN ALL THE
DISTRICTS ACROSS- CALIFORNIA.
AND AS AS WE AFTER NINE ELEVEN
WE- SURGED TOWARDS
INTERNATIONAL TERRORISM
CORRECTLY- YOU KNOW THREE
THOUSAND PEOPLE WERE KILLED ON
NINE ELEVEN AND THAT WAS
DEFINITELY THE THING THAT THE
FBI HAD TO PLUS UP THE JOINT
TERRORISM HAD THE PLOTS UP-
DOMESTIC TERRORISM. AND ANYBODY
WHO'S WORKED- DOMESTIC CARE OR
ANY TYPE OF COUNTERTERRORISM
MISSION WILL TELL YOU THAT
DOMESTIC TERRORISM HAS BEEN THE
SECOND TIER. LEVEL OF
COUNTERTERRORISM I'M LITERALLY
I WORKED THERE FOR TWENTY THREE
YEARS AND- TAUGHT ACROSS THE
COUNTRY IN DOMESTIC TERRORISM
AND MANY TIMES PEOPLE AFTER
PRESENTATION ON DOMESTIC THERE
THAN THEY SAY. THAT'S GREAT
STUFF I WERE COUNTER- THAT'S
REALLY INTERESTING I MIGHT I
WORK COUNTERTERRORISM ALSO
RIGHT I MEAN IT'S- SO- NOW
WE'RE SEEING THE RISE IN
DOMESTIC. TERRORISM OVER THE
PAST- YOU KNOW. SEVEN EIGHT-
PAYER- NO IS THE FBI ABLE TO
TAKE- WITH THE SAME NUMBER OF
PEOPLE- TAKE TO ADDRESS THAT
THAT- THE THREAT OF DOMESTIC
BECAUSE- AS JASON SAID THE
THREAT OF INTERNATIONAL
TERRORISM OR IDEOLOGICALLY
DRIVEN INTERNATIONAL- THREAT
ACTORS. IS HAS NOT GONE AWAY.
RIGHT SO NOW YOU HAVE THE SAME
NUMBER OF AGENTS ARE WORKING
THAT- AND I ARE BOTH SIDES THAT
NEED TO BE WORK EQUALLY- SO I
THINK- THE PLUS UP WILL
DEFINITELY HAVE TO COME IN. AND
NUMBER OF AGENTS- IT'LL ALSO
BE- IN THE YOU KNOW THE NUMBER
F TASK FORCE OFFICERS THAT-
BECAUSE A TASK FORCE OFFICER.
IS ACROSS THE BOARD EQUAL TO AN
AGENT ON THAT JOINT TERRORISM
TASK FORCE FOR THE INTELLIGENCE
FOR THEIR- ARE YOU KNOW ALL
POWERS OF ARREST EVERYTHING.
THAT AN FBI AGENT HAS A JOINT
HEARING TASK FORCE THAT TASK
FORCE OFF THEIR HAT OFF THEIR
HEADS IT'S A FORCE MULTIPLIER.
WHICH IS BEEN USED VERY VERY
WELL- IN COUNTERTERRORISM- YOU
KNOW. ASIANS OVER THE NET IN
THE UNITED STATES- THE SAME
NINE ELEVEN AND- THE CURRENT
DATE SO I DON'T THINK THERE
GOING TO HAVE TO BE A PLUS UP.
OF MANPOWER YOU AS I SAID THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS ASKED FOR
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES- HOPEFULLY
THAT WILL BE- IN IN ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES IN AND- AND-
PERSONNEL ALSO TO ACTUALLY BE
ABLE TO DO THE JOB SO- YEAH I
MEAN. YOU CAN'T HAVE TO
ENTITIES THAT HAVE TO YOU HAVE
TO BE WORKING OUT AND DO WITH
THE SAME NUMBER OF PEOPLE SO.
IT MAKES SENSE YOU HAVE TO BE
AFTER INCREASES IN SOME WAY.
OKAY WITH THAT SAID THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF NO MORE COMMENTS I
DON'T THINK FROM FOR THE FIRST
PANEL. SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AGAIN. TO TOM AND JASON NOW
WILL MOVE ON TO OUR SECOND
PANEL. WELL LET'S BEGIN WITH
THE DIRECTOR MARK PRODUCCI FROM
CAROL YES A MARKER YOUR ARE YOU
THERE. GOOD AFTERNOON- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES MY
HAIR FONG. ALL RIGHT GREAT
THANKS- MISTER GEOGRAPHIA NOON
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY THE
VITAL INFORMATION ABOUT HOW
HELLO YES IN ITS ROLE AS A
STATE HOMELAND SECURITY AGENCY
OPERATES AND- IDENTIFYING HATE
GROUPS AND- WORKING ON DOMESTIC
TERRORISM IN CALIFORNIA. I WANT
TO START OFF THAT REALLY
THANKING TOM AND JASON BECAUSE
I THINK THAT THEY PROVIDED A
GREAT- PICKED ACTUAL FOUNDATION
ADDS TO THE CHALLENGES THAT WE
FACE. HERE IN THE STATE IN THIS
PARTICULAR- ON THIS PARTICULAR
TOPIC THE HOBBIT A GREAT JOB
TALKING ABOUT THE VARIOUS
GROUPS AND WHAT WE'RE SEEING
HERE EACH AND EVERY DAY AND AS
THE GOVERNOR'S HOMELAND
SECURITY ADVISER. I'LL BE THE
FIRST TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE
COMPLEXITY OF THIS CHALLENGE R.
AS IT'S EVER CHANGING AND EVER
EVOLVING ARE IN IT EACH AND
EVERY DAY AND SO WE HAVE TO
REALLY WORK TO STAY OUT IN
FRONT OF IT- TO PROTECT THE
STATE FROM THE ARRAY OF THESE
VERY FIRST THREAT ACTORS. ARE
BEING THE MOST POPULOUS AND
DIVERSE STATE IN CALIFORNIA AND
THE NATION CALIFORNIA PRESENTS
UNIQUE- CHALLENGE THIS MEANS.
THERE ARE HAVE THERE HAS TO BE
AN EQUITABLE DISTRIBUTION OF
ATTENTION AND ALL THE NECESSARY
TOOLS TO LOCAL AND REGIONAL
JURISDICTIONS IN ORDER FOR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES TO BE
KEPT SAFE. HI THIS IS GOT TO BE
A ONE P. ONE FIGHT EFFORT THE
WHOLE OF COMMUNITY APPROACH.
EIGHT IN RECENT YEARS WE'VE
SEEN AN UPTICK IN DOMESTIC
EXTREMIST ACTIVITY AS WELL AS
OTHER THREAT ACTORS OUR STATE-
BUT BEFORE I GET INTO SPECIFICS
I WANT TO GIVE YOU SOME
BACKGROUND ON THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS IN PLACE
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AS PART OF
THE OVERALL STATE HOMELAND
SECURITY ENTERPRISE. CAL
RESIDENT RECEIVES WITHIN THE
HOMELAND SECURITY DIRECTED
DIRECTOR I'M GONNA KIND OF
FOCUS ON PREVENTION DETERRENCE-
AND INTERDICTION IN OUR EFFORTS
TO BUY DOWN THE RISKS THAT WE
ARE WE SEE EACH AND EVERY DAY.
AWESOME ALL START OFF WITH THE
STATE THREAT ASSESSMENT CENTER
OR WE CALL THE STACK THE STACK
IS THE STATE'S PRIMARY FUSION
CENTER AS DESIGNATED BY THE
GOVERNOR. AND HIS HOUSE WITHIN-
WE ASK THE STACK IS A MULTI
AGENCY OUR OF COMPOSITION OF-
OF INDIVIDUALS. FROM VARIOUS
STATE AND FEDERAL AGENCIES IS
CALLING THIS H. P. AND
OBVIOUSLY- YEAH. C. ARE BERMAN
HOMEMADE SECURITY CAL. AND
SERVER DM AFTER ACCESS DRUG.
ALL WERE IN THE SAME.
COLLABORATIVE ENVIRONMENT TO BE
ABLE TO LOOK AT VARIOUS THREATS
AND BREASTS ARE IN BEING ABLE
TO IDENTIFY AS- IN A PROACTIVE.
MANNER THIS TAX SERVICE
CALIFORNIA'S INFORMATION
SHARING CLEARING HOUSES
STATEWIDE STRATEGIC THREAT.
ANALYSIS AND SITUATIONAL
AWARENESS REPORTING TO
STATEWIDE LEADERSHIP AND THE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMUNITY IN
SUPPORT OF EFFORTS TO PREVENT.
PREPARE FOR INVESTIGATE
MITIGATE AND RESPOND ALL CRIMES
AT ALL HAZARDS IT BACK IN
CALIFORNIA CITIZENS. AND ITS
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE WHILE
PRESERVING CIVIL LIBERTIES
INDIVIDUAL PRIVACY AND
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS. THE%
STACKED ESTIMATES STRATEGIC
INTELLIGENCE. FACILITATES
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN LOCAL
STATE AND FEDERAL TRIBAL
AGENCIES AND THE PRIVATE SECTOR
PARTNERS. TO HELP THEM MAKE
INFORMED DECISIONS OR TAKE
ACTIONS ON THREATS AND PUBLIC
SAFETY ISSUES. ONE CRITICAL
COMPONENT OF THE STACK. IS THE
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE
PROTECTION TEAM. THIS TEAM
ASSESSES RISKS TO STATEWIDE
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE THROUGH
A COMBINATION OF OPEN SOURCE
RESEARCH. OUTREACH THE
GOVERNMENT AND PRIVATE SECTOR
PARTNERS ORDINATION OF THE
STATE FUSION CENTER
INFRASTRUCTURE PROTECTION
WORKING GROUP. AN ONSITE
VULNERABILITY ASSESSMENTS THE
TEAM WORKS CLOSELY. AT THE
STATE LEVEL PARTNER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
CYBERSECURITY AND
INFRASTRUCTURE SECURITY AGENCY.
AND FEMA CONCERNING THE
NATIONAL CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE PRIORITIZATION.
PROGRAM SPECIAL EVENTS.
ASSESSMENT KEMAH FACILITIES
TERROR STANDARDS REGIONAL
RESILIENCY ASSESSMENT PROGRAM
AND THE METROPOLITAN
STATISTICAL AREA RISK COREY IN
ADDITION THE HOMELAND SECURITY
DIRECTOR IT ALSO INCLUDES
ACTIVELY WORKING ON THE
FOLLOWING INITIATIVES OR
PROGRAMS MARITIME AND PORT
SECURITY. COMPREHENSIVE SCHOOL
SECURITY LARGE VENUE SPECIAL
EVENTS SECURITY PLANNING
TRANSPORTATION SECURITY.
CREATING SAFER COMMUNITIES
INITIATIVE TERRORISM LIAISON
OFFICER PROGRAM AND THE SEE
SOMETHING SAY SOMETHING
CAMPAIGN. THE STAFF IS ALSO
INTEGRATE TIED TO THE FIVE
REGIONAL FUSION CENTERS WHICH
MAKE UP THE STATE THREAT
ASSESSMENT SYSTEM OR STASHED.
THERE ARE LOCATED IN SACRAMENTO
SAN FRANCISCO LOS ANGELES
ORANGE COUNTY SAN DIEGO.
THROUGH COORDINATED IN
PROCEDURAL INTEL AND
INFORMATION SHARING THE STAFF
WORKS TO SAFEGUARD THE
COMMUNITIES OF CALIFORNIA BY
SERVING AS A DYNAMIC SECURITY
NEXUS COMPRISED OF THE STACK
THE FIRE REGIONAL FUTURES ALSO
ALL. DESIGNATED BY THE GOVERNOR
THE STATE THE STATUS ASSIST IN
THE DETECTION PREVENTION
INVESTIGATION AND RESPONSE THE
CRIMINAL AND TERRORIST ACTIVITY
DISSEMINATE INTELLIGENCE IN THE
SILICATES COMMUNICATIONS
BETWEEN STATE LOCAL FEDERAL AND
TRAVEL PARTNERS AND THE PRIVATE
SECTOR. TO HELP THEM TAKE
ACTION ON THREATS AND PUBLIC
SAFETY ISSUES THE MEMBERS OF
THE STAFF CONSIST OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BRED
ASSESSMENT CENTER OBVIOUSLY
HERE IN SACRAMENTO AND- WE ASK
THE CALIFORNIA- CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA INTELLIGENCE CENTER
WHICH IS THE INLAND. SECTION OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
REGIONAL INTELLIGENCE CENTER
WHICH IS THE LOS ANGELES AND
THAT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. BUT
AREA. THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
REGIONAL INTELLIGENCE CENTER
BASED IN SAN FRANCISCO AND
COVERS MOST OF THE COASTAL
COMMUNITIES THE ORANGE COUNTY
INTELLIGENCE CENTER AND THE SAN
DIEGO LAW ENFORCEMENT
COORDINATION CENTER WHICH NOT
ONLY HAS SAN DIEGO AND-
IMPERIAL COUNTIES BUT OBVIOUSLY
A VERY VERY ACTIVE BORDER. ALL
OF THE STAFF CENTERS ARE INTER
AGENCY STAFF OF PERSONNEL FROM
MULTIPLE AGENCIES ACROSS.
VARIOUS SECTORS. SO MUCH STOP
FOR A SECOND A TURN OVER TO TOM
OSBORNE- TOM IS THE MY DEPUTY-
WHO OVERSEES THE DAILY
OPERATIONS OF OUR HOMELAND
SECURITY DIRECTORATE IT'S GOING
TO PROVIDE A LITTLE BIT MORE
CONTEXT ON. SOME OF THE
OPERATIONAL ASPECTS OF WHAT WE
DO. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU DIRECTOR AND GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR VICE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF. THE COMMITTEE. AND
THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE
HOMELAND SECURITY DIVISION
HERE- THAT- YES AS THE DIRECTOR
SAID. PRIOR TO MY CURRENT
POSITION HERE AT ALL YES I
SPENT NEARLY TWENTY FOUR YEARS
WITH THE FBI. PRIMARILY FOCUSED
ON NATIONAL SECURITY THREAT
ISSUES THAT INCLUDE THE
INTERNATIONAL AND DOMESTIC
TERRORISM THREATS.
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE THREATS AND
OUR CYBER THREAT SO I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO HAVE A DISCUSSION ON THE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE EXTREMISM
THREAD ISSUE AND HOW WE CAN
BETTER PROTECT THE CITIZENS- UP
CALIFORNIA. FIRST I'D LIKE TO
DESCRIBE OUR CALIFORNIA STATE
WIDE THREAT ASSESSMENT PROCESS.
WHICH LARGELY MIRRORS THE F. B.
I.'S. THREAT REVIEW AND
PRIORITIZATION PROCESS WHICH
THEY REFER TO AS THE TRPV FOUR
ON AN ANNUAL BASIS ARE THREATS
ARE EXAMINED AND RESOURCES ARE
PRIORITIZED BASED UPON- THOSE
THREATS- AND SO THIS. PROCESS
MY PROCESS IT'S DONE ANNUALLY
BY THE STATE ASSESSMENT CENTER
OR THE STACK IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THE STATE'S HOUSING ALL OF
OUR FUSION CENTERS PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED AND THEN SECONDLY I
WILL PROVIDE A SUMMARY OF OUR
CURRENT THREAT ENVIRONMENT
BASED UPON THIS METHODOLOGY.
THE CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE THREAT
ASSESSMENT REPORT VIEWS THE
THREAT LANDSCAPE OF CALIFORNIA
IN THREE CATEGORIES CRIMINAL
CYBER AND EXTREMISM WE FORMALLY
USED TO BECAUSE YOU KNOW THE
TERRORISM. THE DOUBLE MENTAL
STATUS WIDE JOINT METHODOLOGY
TO ESTABLISH A COMPREHENSIVE
UNDERSTANDING OF THE EXISTING
EMERGING AND ANTICIPATED
THREATS IN CALIFORNIA. IT
IDENTIFIES AND PRIORITIZES TOP
CRIMINAL CYBER
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE AND
EXTREMISM. THREATS REGIONALLY
AND STATEWIDE. THIS INTELLIGENT
FRONT THIS INTELLIGENCE
PRODUCTS SERVES AS A RESOURCE
FOR GOVERNMENT EXECUTIVES
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES FIRST
RESPONDERS THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY TO MAINTAIN AWARENESS
OF CURRENT AND EMERGING THREATS
AND TRENDS TWO YEARS OF
DEVELOPMENT OF STATEWIDE
MITIGATION STRATEGIES WHICH ARE
INCORPORATED INTO OUR
CALIFORNIA HOMELAND SECURITY
STRATEGY. IN CALIFORNIA. I'M
STILL HITTING THE CALIFORNIA
STATE WIDE THREAT ASSESSMENT
THE TOP KEY THREAT ACTORS AND
Q. THREAT ISSUES ARE IDENTIFIED
BY THE STAFF USING A COMPLEX
ANNUAL STATEWIDE ASSESSMENT
PROCESS THIS PROCESS INCLUDING
UNIFORM SCORING MATRIX USED BY
EACH STASHED FUSION CENTER
AGAINST A COMMON LIST OF THREAT
ACTORS FROM SHARED MASTER
THREAT LIST THE TOP KEY THREAT
ISSUES ARE DERIVED FROM
IDENTIFIED ISSUE AREAS AS
PROVIDED BY THE RECIPIENTS OF
THE UP THE SURVEY AND THROUGH
OUR INTERACTION WITH THE
CENTERS. WHEN A KEY THREAT
ISSUED IDENTIFIED BY FOR MORE
THE FUSION CENTERS THIS ADDED
TO THE KEY THREAT ISSUES LESS
THIS IS A PROCESS THAT ENSURES
THAT WOULD NOT ONLY WE FOCUSED
ON OUR TOP THREAT ISSUES BUT
IDENTIFYING NEW AND EMERGING
THREATS FACING THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THE. TWENTY TWENTY ONE-
BASICALLY RECALL THAT WE DID AS
A CAL STATE WHY THRUST OF MY
REPORT- CALIFORNIA THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD IT
IS THE MOST POPULOUS AND
DIVERSE STATE IN THE COUNTRY.
EIGHT OF THE UNITED STATES
FIFTY MOST POPULOUS STATES
RESIDE IN CALIFORNIA AS DOES
THE WORLD'S BUSIEST LAND BORDER
CROSSINGS ALISON DROVE THE
WORLD'S PREMIER CENTER UP
TECHNOLOGICAL INNOVATION AND
SILICON VALLEY. THE BUSIEST
CARGO PORT ON THE PACIFIC COAST
OF NORTH AMERICA LONG BEACH ST
UNITED STATES LARGEST.
PRODUCING REGION THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AS WELL AS SEVERAL
CULTURAL DESTINATIONS THAT
ATTRACT MILLIONS OF DOMESTIC
AND FOREIGN INVESTORS INTO
CALIFORNIA EVERY YEAR. WHILE
THESE FEATURES HELP DESCRIBE
CALIFORNIA SIZE AND SCALE THEY
ALSO MAKE CALIFORNIA POTENTIAL
ACTIVE TARGET TO FOREIGN
ADVERSARIES TRANS NATIONAL
CRIMINAL ORGANIZATIONS. AND
VIOLENT DOMESTIC AND
INTERNATIONAL EXTREMOS
MOTIVATED BY A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT IDEOLOGIES. FOR
PERSONAL VARIABLES. SO FROM THE
CRIMINAL CATEGORY FROM THIS
REPORT A PERSISTENT SPENDING
DURING THREAT FROM MEXICO BASED
TRANS NATIONAL CRIMINAL
ORGANIZATIONS. STREET GANGS
PRISON GANGS AND ORGANIZED
CRIMINAL GROUPS REMAIN A TOP
THREAT ISSUE FACING THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. THESE THREAT
ACTORS CONTRIBUTE TO CALIFORNIA
BEING THE ILLICIT DRUG GATEWAY
FROM MEXICO INTO THE UNITED
STATES THROUGH OUR LAND AND
MARITIME ENVIRONMENTS. FROM OUR
SERVER CATEGORY CALIFORNIA
CITIZENS AND BUSINESSES ARE
UNDER CONSTANT ATTACK AND
THREATS FROM NATION STATE
NATION STATE ACTORS CRIMINAL
CYBER CRIMINALS AND MALICIOUS
INSIDERS RECENT EXAMPLES OF A
SUPPLY CHAIN ATTACK BY OUR
STATE SPONSORED ADVERSARIES
HIGHLIGHT HOW IMPACTFUL. THESE
COMPROMISES CAN BE TO THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND TO THE
OVERALL ECONOMY YEAH IN THE
UNITED STATES AND CALIFORNIA.
FROM THE EXTREMISM CATEGORY
FOREIGN TERRORIST ORGANIZATIONS
PRESENT A PERSISTENT AND
ENDURING THREAT CONTINUALLY
TRYING TO DIRECT INSPIRE AND OR
NAVAL ATTACKS AGAINST THE
HOMELAND BEDTIMES EXPLICITLY
CALLING OUT TARGETS IN
CALIFORNIA. THE CALIFORNIA
STATE FRONT OF CERTAIN CENTER
OF THE STACK ALONG WITH OUR
FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY PARTNERS HAVE NOTED A
STARTER KIT CELEBRATION OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE STREAM ISM.
RADICALIZATION CALL FOR
MOBILIZATION ATTACK PLOTTING
AND ATTEMPTS IN RECENT YEARS
CERTAINLY A PARADIGM SHIFT FROM
THE H. B. THAT HERE TO A
FOREIGN TERRORIST ORGANIZATION
IDEOLOGY. AS MUCH NO LONGER
PRESENTS REPRESENTS THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT THREATS THE UNITED
STATES. WHAT'S THAT REMAINS
CONCERNED ABOUT THE POTENTIAL
FOR LOOSELY ORGANIZED OR
INDIVIDUAL DVDS MOBILIZING FOR
VIOLENCE TO TARGET FEDERAL
STATE AND LOCAL ELECTED
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS AND
POLITICAL PARTY
REPRESENTATIVES. CONTINUE.
DISCUSSIONS AND- PERPETUATION
OF MISS AND DISINFORMATION
NARRATIVES OF ELECTION FRAUD IN
OPPOSITION TO ANTICIPATED
ACTIONS OF NEWLY ELECTED
EXECUTIVE AND LEGISLATIVE
BRANCHES OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT MAINLY. SOME
INDIVIDUALS TO ADOPT THE
BELIEVE THAT VIOLENT ACTION IS
NECESSARY. THE JANUARY SIX U.
S. CASUALTIES FOSTERED AN IN
PERSON ENGAGEMENT BETWEEN DVDS
OF WHICH APPROXIMATELY TWENTY
TWO INDIVIDUALS TRAVELED FROM
CALIFORNIA- TO THAT EVENT. WAS
SUPPORTED VARYING IDEOLOGIES
THE SHARING SIMILAR GOALS WHICH
MAY LEAD TO AN INCREASE IN DVD
CAPABILITIES COORDINATION AND
MOTIVATION TO ATTACK AND
UNDERMINE ELECTED OFFICIALS OR
POLITICAL PARTY REPRESENTATIVES
IF YOU AS- ILLEGITIMATE. I'M
GOING FORCED EFFORTS TO ARREST
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE PRETENDING
WHO PARTICIPATED IN THE U. S.
CAPITOL SEATS LARGELY DRIVEN BY
THE JOINT TERRORISM TASK FORCES
COULD DETER SOME DVDS. AND LEAD
OTHERS TO INCREASE THEIR
OPERATIONAL SECURITY MEASURES
TO REDUCE LAW ENFORCEMENT
SCRUTINYBY THE USE OF
ENCRYPTED APPS ON OUR PHONES-
REALLY PARALYZING THE LONG
CORPORATE COMMUNITY TO
INTERCEPT THESE ATTACKS
PLOTTED. SOME DVDS WILL VERY
LIKELY CONTINUE TO TRANSITION
TO A MORE SECURE ONLINE
COMMUNICATION PLATFORM AS I
JUST MENTIONED. FUTURE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE REMIX ACTIVITY IS VERY
LIKELY TO BE INFLUENCED BY A
VARIETY OF TOPICS TO INCLUDE
OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL MONTHS
LAW ENFORCEMENT USE OF FORCE
DISCUSSIONS. THE CURRENT
POLITICAL CLIMATE SUMMARIZED
DISCUSSIONS IN CULVER NINETEEN
POLICIES THESE ARE ALLDRIVERS-
IN OUR CURRENT ENVIRONMENT FOR
WHICH WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. THIS
ASSESSMENT IS BASED UPON RECENT
EVENTS IN CALIFORNIA AND THE
UNITED STATES AND THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT DISCUSSION
REGARDING THESE TOPICS. WILL
NOT BE RESOLVED IN THE
IMMEDIATE FUTURE. ALSO ONE OF
THE HIGHLIGHTS SOME OF THE
SUSPICIOUS ACTIVITY REPORTS
THAT I KNOW MISTER SENATE THE
NIGRICANS JOHNNY TALK ABOUT AS
OUR FUSION SHOPS CENTER
REPRESENTED FROM A STATEWIDE-
VIEW ARTS THE STARS OR
SUSPICIOUS ACTIVITY REPORTS ARE
OFFICIAL DOCUMENTED.
OBSERVATION EIGHT YOU'RE
REASONABLY INDICATIVE OF PRE
OPERATIONAL PLANNING ASSOCIATE
WITH TERRORISM OR OTHER
CRIMINAL ACTIVITY. YEAR OVER
YEAR CALIFORNIA GENERATES ON
AVERAGE APPROXIMATELY FIFTY
FIVE HUNDRED SARS- BY ALL OF
THE REGIONAL FUSION CENTERS ARE
MENTIONED BELOW ARE. AT STAKE
APPROXIMATELY 40% OF THOSE
STARS ARE REFERRED DIRECTLY TO
THE JOINT TERRORISM TASK FORCE
FOR FURTHER LAW. ENFORCEMENT-
ENGAGEMENT. SPECIFICALLY OR OF
EAGAR- RECORDS AND THAT'S KIND
OF THE STARS ARE GOING TO BE
GUARDING ELECTRONIC SYSTEM FOR
SHARING INDICATES THAT FROM THE
FIRST OF JANUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY TO THE THIRTY FIRST OF
MARCH. A TOTAL OF NINETEEN
HUNDRED CALIFORNIA BASED STARS
WERE REPORTED. OF WHICH TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN OF THOSE
WERE DIRECTLY- RELATED TO
DEVIATE ACTIVITIES SO
APPROXIMATELY 11% OF CURRENT
STARS COMING THROUGH OUR
VISITORS ARE RELATED TO THIS
THREAT ISSUE. LASTLY ONE OF OUR
CORE FUNCTIONS AT THE STACK IS
TO CERTAINLY SHARE- IN
INTELLIGENCE INFORMATION WITH
OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
COMMUNITY PARTNERS VIA ALERTS
AND BULLETINS AND DIFFERENT
INTELLIGENCE PRODUCTS. AS SUCH-
DURING THAT SAME TIME PERIOD WE
GENERATED OVER TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY NINE ALERTS AND
BULLETINS WERE SENT OUT TO.
THESE ENTITIES I JUST MENTIONED
AND THESE WERE ALL ROUGHLY. 20%
OF OUR PRODUCTS DISSEMINATED ON
THE DVD THREAT SOMEONE TO
PREVENT PREVENT. PRESENT YOU
KNOW KIND OF OUR CURRENT THREAT
PICTURE- AND DIRECTOR OF TURN
IT BACK OVER TO YOU. THANKS
TALK. IT OUT OF IT'S IMPORTANT
YOU KNOW OUR MISSION REALLY IS
TO SECURE AND PREPARE
CALIFORNIA IT'S PEOPLE A
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE ON THE
THREATS UPON JUST TALKED ABOUT
AND OUR PREVIOUS PRESENTERS.
I'VE NEVER BEEN MORE IMORTANT
PARTICULARLY NOW WITH THE
INCREASE IN HATE GROUPS AND
DOMESTIC TERRORISM WHERE WE SEE
MUCH DISCUSSION IMMOBILIZATION
DURING CRICKET CHAT ROOMS
SOCIAL MEDIA ACCOUNTS ON THE
DARK WEB. IS AN ONGOING EFFORT
THAT REQUIRES CONSTANTFOCUS
AND ATTENTION BOTH ON THE
GROUND AND ON THE WEB. AND
THAT'S ONE OF THE OTHER REASONS
WHY- WITH OUR OUR NEW
CALIFORNIA CYBERSECURITY
INTEGRATION CENTER- PLAY SUCH A
CRITICAL ROLE WE CALL THE CAL
SECTOR CAL SICK REALLY SERVES
AS THAT CENTRAL ORGANIZING HUB.
OF STATE GOVERNMENT
CYBERSECURITY ACTIVITIES AND
COORDINATES THE INFORMATION
SHARING AT THE VARIOUS LEVELS
OF GOVERNMENT- AND WITH THE
PRIVATE SECTOR AND UTILITIES
AND OTHER SERVICE PROVIDERS
ACADEMIC INSTITUTIONS AND NON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS.
THESE SERVICES INCLUDE PROGRAM
ELEMENTS SUCH AS OVERARCHING
CYBERSECURITY STRATEGIES
INTELLIGENCE ANALYSIS
CONNECTING THE DOTS IF YOU WAIT
BETWEEN- WHAT WE'RE SEEING
ONLINE WHAT WE'RE SEEING IN THE
DARK WEB. BEING ABLE TO USE THE
TOOLS ARE TO BE ABLE TO GET
THAT INFORMATION. IN SPANISH IT
FOR INCIDENT RESPONSE. AGAIN
MADE UP OF MULTIPLE AGENCIES
AND ORGANIZATIONS IT IS A
COLLABORATIVE. INTEGRATED
EFFORT AND- THAT THE STAFFS-
AND THE CAL SICK ALL WORKING
PROACTIVELY TOGETHER IN CONCERT
THE BILL THE RESILIENCY AT THE
AT THE VARIOUS LOCAL STATE AND
THE REGIONAL LEVEL ARCHITECT TO
ENSURE COMMUNITY SECURITY AND
ECONOMIC SECURITY. AND
PROTECTION OF THE CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE IS CRITICAL ALL
OF THESE THINGS PLAY INTO- THE
DECISIONS THAT ARE MADE. TO
EITHER RAMP UP OR RAMP DOWN SO
POSTURE ALL OF THESE AT. THIS
AND TELL THAT ARE GETTING FROM
THE MULTIPLE SOURCES GIVE US-
AN INDICATOR AS TO CREDIBILITY
UP THREATS. OR MAKING HELPING
US TO MAKE THE DECISION AS TO
WHAT KIND OF RESOURCES WE NEED
TO FOCUS OR FUN- TO GET THERE
WE ALSO HAVE A VERY ROBUST-
HOMELAND SECURITY ADVISORY
COMMITTEE WHICH IS REALLY. MADE
UP OF MULTIPLE LEADERS FROM
ACROSS THE SPECTRUM IN IN IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA FEDERAL
STATE LOCAL PRIVATE SECTOR
ORGANIZATIONS THE BODY ADVISES-
MYSELF THE HOMELAND SECURITY
ADVISER ON CURRENT SECURITY
THREATS AND PRIORITIES. IN AN
EFFORT TO PROVIDE AND PROMOTE A
UNIFIED APPROACH SO THAT WERE
COORDINATED ACROSS THE STATE
EVEN THOUGH EACH REGION HAS ITS
OWN REAL SIGNATURE WITH REGARDS
TO THE KIND OF. OF THREATS THAT
THE POPULATION BASED THAT THAT
THE DEMOGRAPHICS WE DO TRY TO
BUILD A STATEWIDE. EFFORT AND I
STATEWIDE UNIFIED APPROACH IN
OUR HOMELAND SECURITY STRATEGY.
AS YOU'VE HEARD AND WILL
CONTINUE TO HEAR TODAY THERE
ARE MANY. STRATEGIES AND
TACTICS USED TO COMBAT THE
GROWING THREAT OF THE DOMESTIC
TERRORISM. IT MAY BE HELPFUL
THAT THAT I BRIEFLY JUST TOUCH
UPON OUR HOMELAND SECURITY
GRANTS AND HOW THEY'RE INVESTED
TO BUILD RESILIENCY AND PREVENT
AND RESPOND TO ACTS. OF
TERRORISM- WE GET GRAY FROM THE
S. THE OF HOMELAND SECURITY-
PER THAT GUIDELINES EACH STATE
RECEIVES ALL FUNDING MUST
DESIGNATE UP TO TEN INVESTMENT
JUSTIFICATIONS FOR THAT FUNDS
THAT FOCUS ON FUNDING
PRIORITIES FOR EACH YEAR EACH
INVESTMENT JUSTIFICATION MUST
DEMONSTRATE HOW. PROPOSED
INVESTMENTS SUPPORT TERRORISM
PREPAREDNESS. CLOSE CAPABILITY
GAPS OR SUSTAIN EXISTING
CAPABILITIES AND ALSO SUPPORT
ADDRESSING ANY LOGISTICAL
TECHNOLOGICAL LEGAL POLICY OR
OTHER IMPEDIMENTS TO FOSTER A
CULTURE OF STATE AND NATIONAL
PARENTS. THIS FUNDING SUSTAINS
A CONTINUAL EFFORT TO PREVENT
PREPARE FOR PROTECT AGAINST
RESPOND TO ACTS OF TERRORISM
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. EACH YEAR
CALIFORNIA DEVELOPS UP TO TEN
SUCH INVESTMENT JUSTIFICATIONS
BASED UPON IMPORT FROM THE
HOMELAND SECURITY ADVISORY
COMMITTEE THAT I MENTIONED
EARLIER. BOTH THE INVESTMENT
JUSTIFICATION AND THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE ARE MULTI
JURISDICTIONAL FORMS ARE
INCLUDE MANY MANY DIFFERENT
AGENCIES. IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWENTY ONE THE INVESTMENT
JUSTIFICATION LAST ARE- FOR
CALIFORNIA INCLUDE THE
FOLLOWING. TO ENHANCE
INFORMATION INTELLIGENCE
SHARING AND COOPERATION WITH
FEDERAL AGENCIES. INCLUDING
DEPARTMENT HOMELAND SECURITY
FBI ENHANCE IN THE PROTECTION
OF SOFT TARGETS. PRODDED PLACES
ARE ENHANCE CYBERSECURITY
ADDRESS A MERGING THREATS.
COMBAT DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
EXTREMISM THROUGH ENHANCED
INTELLIGENCE COLLECTION
ANALYSIS TRAINING AND COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE. STRENGTHENING
COMMUNITY COMMUNICATIONS
CAPABILITIES WE'RE PLANNING
GOVERNANCE TECHNOLOGY
DEPARTMENT ENHANCE MEDICAL AND
PUBLIC HEALTH PREPAREDNESS
STRICT INTERPRETATION SHARING
COLLABORATION ENHANCE COMMUNITY
CAPABILITIES TO MULTI
JURISDICTIONAL IN A
JURISDICTIONAL ALL HAZARD
PLANNING. AND PROTECT CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE IN KEY RESOURCES
AS YOU CAN SEE THESE TEN
INVESTMENT EXPECTATIONS ARE
BROUGHT AND IT GIVES. US AN
ABILITY TO PROVIDE THE FRAME BY
WE BUILD A AND ME THE CIGNA. OF
UNIQUE IS OF OUR VARIOUS
REGIONS WHILE STILL BOUGHT A
BUILDING IN AN OVERARCHING
STRATEGY FOR THE STATE AND THAT
STRATEGY ALSO TAKES INTO
ACCOUNT THE THREAT ASSESSMENT
PROCESS THAT TOM HAD MENTIONED.
EARLIER SO BOB. ALL OF THIS IS
WRAPPED IT TOGETHER THEN INTO-
AN ANNUAL STATE ONLY INSECURITY
STRATEGY THE STRATEGY IS
CALIFORNIA'S ROAD MAP TOWARDS
ENHANCING OUR CAPABILITIES AND
REDUCING AND MITIGATING THE
REST IT ENSURES THAT WE ARE
MEASURING THREE THROUGH
OBJECTIVES THE EFFORTS THAT
WE'RE PUTTING FORTH SO
CALIFORNIA ACROSS THE BOARD IN
ALL THE VARIOUS SECTORS WITH
ALL OF THE VARIOUS THREATS ARE
BEING ADDRESSED IT IN EVEN IN
AND- AND UNIFIED MANNER AND
THAT THE PURPOSE OF THIS. ITS
OVER ARCHING- STRATEGY IS
REALLY THE SEP FOURTH OF OUR
STATE'S HOMELAND SECURITY'S
PRIORITIES FROM THE STATE LEVEL
ALL THE WAY DOWN TO OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES ESTABLISHED
PERFORMANCE METRICS TO MEASURE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE STRATEGY
AND ALIGN AND INTEGRATE THESE
PRAYER OR AT PRIORITIES WHICH
STATEWIDE FUNDING AS IT BECOMES
AVAILABLE AND FUNDING COMES
FROM AGAIN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT BUT ALSO UP THROUGH
SOME STATE LEVEL- FUNDING. AS A
PART OF THE UPDATE THE STATE'S
HOMEMADE SECURITY STRATEGY FOR
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE
DOMESTIC BONTA EXTREMISM HAS
BEEN IDENTIFIED AS ONE OF THE
TOP HOMELAND SECURITY THREATS
FACING THE STATE THE STRATEGY
HAS IDENTIFIED SEVERAL
OBJECTIVES WITH THE NEXUS TO
COMBATING DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
EXTREMISM MOVING FORWARD TO
INCLUDE ENHANCING THE STATE'S.
TERRACE AND LYFT OFFICER
PROGRAM. I THINK THE STATE'S
THREAT ASSESSMENTS PLAY PROCESS.
IMPROVING AMONGST THE STATUS
INTELLIGENCE ANALYSTS ACQUIRING
NEW RISK ASSESSMENT AND THREAT
MODELING AND ANALYSIS TOOLS.
CONDUCTING STATEWIDE DROUGHT
ASSESSMENTS IDENTIFY CURRENT
AND EMERGENCY EMERGING THREATS
IN THIS SPACE FACING THE STATE.
DEVELOPING TO RESOURCES FOR
FIRST RESPONDERS AND OWNERS AND
OPERATORS OF SOFT TARGETS AND
CROWDED PLACES ARE BEST
PRACTICE IN MITIGATING THESE
TERRORIST THREATS. CONDUCTING
RESEARCH ON STATE OF
DISINFORMATION AND
MISINFORMATION ON HATE
PREVENTION PROGRAMS IN A
DIGITAL AND SOCIAL MEDIA
LANDSCAPE. ARE PRODUCING POLICY
PROPOSALS ON LOCAL OP VIOLENCE
PREVENTION EFFORTS TO BE MADE
TO BE AVAILABLE TO STATEWIDE
STAKEHOLDERS AND LASTLY
ENHANCING STATEWIDE TRAINING
RESOURCES IN THE AREA OF
DIGITAL MEDIA LITERACY. RATE
REDUCTION TARGET VIOLENCE
PREVENTION AND
COUNTERTERRORISM. AS IT'S BEEN
DESCRIBED. THE THREAT OF
DOMESTIC TERRORISM. AND
EXTREMIST ACTIVITY IS MULTI
DIMENSIONAL REQUIRES A COMPLEX
NETWORK OF HOMELAND SECURITY
INITIATIVES TO COMBAT IT'S
IMPERATIVE THAT WE CONTINUE TO
ENSURE A ROBUST WHOLE OF
COMMUNITY APPROACH. TO
SUSTAINING AND BUILDING
CAPABILITIES ACROSS THE
HOMELAND SECURITY ENTERPRISE.
SUCH AN APPROACH NECESSITATE
ENGAGEMENT FROM INDIVIDUALS
FAMILIES. COMMUNITIES PRIVATE
NONPROFIT SECTOR FAITH BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. AT ALL LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT. COULD SHE THIS. WE
WILL CONTINUE A MULTI
DISCIPLINARY MULTI
JURISDICTIONAL CAPABILITY IN
PLANNING ORGANIZING EQUIPPING
TRAINING AND EXERCISING ACROSS
ALL. SECTORS IN THE PREVENTION
PROTECTION MITIGATION RESPONSE
RECOVERY OF THE MISSIONARIES
THANKS SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY AT PGA- PROJECT THE TOPIC
AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU DIRECTOR
NOW WE'LL HEAR FROM JOHN
STEDMAN DIRECTOR OF THE JOINT
REGIONAL INTELLIGENCE CENTER-
JOHN EITHER. YES SIR CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES WE HEAR OKAY VERY
GOOD SIR THANK YOU A GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN RODRIGUEZ
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS JOHN STATEMENT-
CURRENTLY I HOLD THE TITLE OF
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE DRUG
REGIONAL INTELLIGENCE CENTER-
WE'RE DOWN HERE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA HEADQUARTERED LOS
ANGELES BUT WE COVER. SIX
COUNTIES INCLUDING LOS ANGELES
NUMBER NEAR RIVERSIDE. VENTURA
SANTA BARBARA AND SAN LUIS
OBISPO. REPRESENT MORE THAN.
FIFTEEN MILLION RESIDENTS IN
THE STATE HUNDRED FIFTY
POLICING AGENCIES. AND A
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE FIRE
DEPARTMENTS THE GENERAL A. O.
R. IS COMPLEX AND UNIQUE AND
GOT THE SAME HIGH DENSITY URBAN
AREAS. AS WELL GROWING PLACE IN
THE MOUNTAINS DESERT AND
COASTAL ZONES. ALTHOUGH WHAT
I'M ALSO GOING TO DISCUSS ABOUT
THE JERRY YOU CAN FUTHER THAT
MOST WANT TO TALK ABOUT ARE THE
CORE COMPETENCIES OF MOST OF
THE FUSION CENTER HERE IN
CALIFORNIA- I READ THE VICE
CHAIR SPEAK- ABOUT WE'VE BEEN
DOING THIS A LONG TIME. HERE
THE FACT WE WRITE. SOME GOOD
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT HISTORY
MARIE HOW WE GOT TO WHERE WE
ARE TODAY. AND THEN WE'LL TALK
ABOUT SOME SPECIFIC PROCESSES
THAT HAVE BEEN. SORT OF
SOCIALIZED THROUGHOUT THAT
FUSION CENTER NETWORK. THE
JERRY GETS UP AND FOUNDED IN
TWO THOUSAND SIX IT WAS AN
OUTGROWTH OF THE LOS ANGELES.
DODGERS MEMORY WARNING GROUP-
THAT WAS ESTABLISHED IN
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT- AND WHEN
IT WAS OPRATIONAL TELEFONICA
JERRY PART WAS PULLED AND THE
DELIVERY SYSTEM X. P. A
CONSERVATIVE SEVENTEEN
SEPARATE. GROUPS AROUND THE
COUNTRY FROM COOPERATING CITIES
AND COUNTIES- SEVENTY THOUSAND
SIX SUPPORTED BY THE US
DEPARTMENT HOMELAND SECURITY
GW'S ROCKY BOLTED INTO WHAT IS
NOW THE NATIONAL FUSION CENTER
NETWORK. I NEVER PERSONALLY I
LIKE MY CHANNEL TALK A BIT MORE
ABOUT THAT BUT THERE IS HAT
CURRENTLY BUT ET. SEPARATE
FUSION CENTERS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. ALL FEDERALLY FOR BUT
LET GOT AND SO WITH- THE JERK
SPECIFICALLY WHAT'S GREAT AS AN
INTELLIGENCE COLLABORATION
BETWEEN THE F. B. I. LAPD AND
THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT HERE
IN LA. OTHER PARTNERS ARE FROM
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY
FIRE SERVICE HEALTHCARE
ORGANIZATIONS- ALSO JOINED AT
THAT TIME- JERRY NOW SPONSORED
ABOUT TWENTY TWO DIFFERENT
AGENCIES FEDERAL. STATE LOCAL
I. HERE TO JERICHO. SOME OF THE
PART TIME AND SUMMER FULL TIME.
A LOT OF THE L. A. T. W. WHICH
BEGAN TO GENERATE CONSULTAS
FICTIONAL APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING TERRORISM WHICH WAS
ITS ORIGINAL MANDATE. OR THERE
IS THE GENERIC LIKE MOST FUSION
CENTERS IN BOSTON ALL THREATS
CENTER ADDRESSING TRADITIONAL
AND EMERGING THREATS WITHIN IT
AND I EACH. GAIL ARE FROM THE
BEGINNING THE JERICA BENNETT A
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT THE FIRE SERVICE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
MEDICAL. SERVICES AND THE
PRIVATE SECTOR THROUGH THE END
FOR GUARD PROGRAM RUN BY THE
FBI FBI BUT LOCATED IN THE
CENTER HERE. EACH PARTNER
BRINGS A UNIQUE PERSPECTIVE THE
ANALYTICAL PROCESS TO BUILD A
COMPLETE PICTURE OF THREATS.
WHETHER THEY INVOLVE
TRADITIONAL CRIMINAL
ORGANIZATIONS WEAPONS OF MASS
DESTRUCTION OR THREATS TO
PUBLIC HEALTH. ONLY RECENTLY
SELECTED AS THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR HERE I HAVE EXTENSIVE
EXPERIENCE ADDRESSING EXTREMIST
VIOLENCE GANDER IN MY PRIOR
POSITION. AS THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMANDER AND EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT COMMANDING OFFICER
FOR THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT. THE FIRST
BIG BROTHER JERICA COMMISSION I
WOULD LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT SOME
LOCAL REGIONAL NATIONAL
INITIATIVE THAT HISTORICALLY
ADDRESSED ISSUES OF EXTREMISM
AT AND HAVE HAD A SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT. ON THE VISION CENTER
CONCEPT. MY PRIOR CAREER TO
SHERIFF DEPARTMENT I WAS
FORTUNATE TO BE SELECTED TO
REPRESENT MY AGENCY ON BOTH A
MAJOR CITIES CHIEFS AND MAJOR
COUNTY SHERIFF'S INTEL
COMMANDER OF GROUPS. BOTH IT
ORGANIZATIONS WORK POWER
FIRELESS LATE. REGARDING-
DEVELOP A PROTOCOL BASICALLY
FOR SHARING SPECIAL SUSPICIOUS
ACTIVITY REPORTING REGARDING
DOMESTIC AND INTERNATIONAL
EXTREMIST BEHAVIOR AND
PROVIDING LOCAL AND REGIONAL
INPUT CAN APPLE DIRECTORS OF
INTELLIGENCE COLLECTION FOR THE
FEDERAL BUREAU OF INVESTIGATION
DEPARTMENT HOMELAND SECURITY
AND OTHER MEMBERS OF THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE. RECALLS
IMPORTANT INDEED ASSOCIATION
FOR INSTRUMENTAL IN THE
PHILOSOPHICALLY SUPPORTING THE
ESTABLISHMENT GROWTH AND
FUNDING FOR NATIONAL PEOPLE
CENTER NETWORK. IN FACT MANY OF
THE MEMBERS OF THE CHIEFS AND
SHERIFFS ASSOCIATIONS ARE
FORMER. LIKE MYSELF CURRENT
FUSION CENTERDIRECTORS.
RELATIONSHIPS DEVELOP BY THESE
ASSOCIATIONS HAVE MATURED OVER
THE YEARS TO THE BENEFIT OF ALL
THE INDEPENDENT AGENCIES AS
WELL AS A FUSION CENTER NETWORK.
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMANDER TO
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT I WAS A
PART OF THE JERRICK. ELEMENT OF
A STATEWIDE SYSTEM IT WAS CLEAR
THAT SUCH A SYSTEM. JACK
EXISTING CALIFORNIA BUILD
MULTIPLE COUNTSIN THE
COLLECTION AND DISSEMINATION OF
INTELLIGENCE ISSUES. SO DO YOU
BELIEVE THAT OR TO TALK ABOUT
TODAY SO THE JERICHO ARE THE
THIRD MANY INSTANCES OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE EXTREMISM.
THE BOTTOM LINE UP FRONT VITAL
EXTREMISM AND BEEN HERE FOR A
LONG TIME AND REMAINS A
PERENNIAL CONCERN. THAT'S LOCAL
AGENCIES HAVE BEEN ACTIVE IN
THE COUNTER TERRORISM COUNTER
EXTREMISM MISSION FOR A LONG
TIME INDIVIDUALLY AS WELL AS
COLLABORATIVE LEE AT CENTER
LIKE THE GENERAL. TERRORISM AND
EXTREMISM ARE NOT THE MOST
FREQUENT CHALLENGES FACED BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT. AND THE PUBLIC
SAFETY PARTNERS BUT THEY WILL
REMAIN A PERSISTENT CONCERN IN
THE FUTURE. ONE FREQUENT
OUTSIDE IMPACT ON POLITICS
FINDING RESOURCES OPERATIONS
AND OVERSIGHT. WHEN WE LOOK AT
SPECIFIC INCIDENTS THAT OCCUR
IN THE AREA ARE WE REALLY LOOK
AT HOW THEY CAN BE SHARED AMONG
HER PARTNERS AND WHAT WE MIGHT
DO IN REACTION TO THOSE SO-
MOST OF PEOPLE CENTERS ARE NOT
OPERATIONAL WE DON'T HAVE
INVESTIGATIVE ARMS. BUT WE CAN
LEARN FROM WHAT OCCURS AND
PROVIDE TRAINING OR SUPPORT TO
OUR LOCAL PARTNERS. BUT
INSTEAD- INCIDENT IN TWO
THOUSAND FIVE PROBABLY
EVERYBODY HEARD ABOUT IT IT WAS
A- RADICAL GROUP THAT IT
EMANATED OUT OF THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS. J.
I. S. WHICH MEANS. ASSOCIATION
APPROVES FONG I WON'T ATTEND
THE ARABIC TRANSLATION OF THAT
BECAUSE I WOULD JUST DESTROY IT
BUT- IT WAS- A SMALL GROUP OF
PRISONERS BASICALLY INSIDE THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS IF
THEY STARTED A CELL BASED ON A
CORRECTED VERSION OF ISLAM. A
NAME THEMSELVES THEY CREATED A
MANIFESTO DEALING THEIR
GRIEVANCES AGAINST UNITED
STATES MILITARY INJURY JEWISH
ORGANIZATIONS THROUGH THE
REQUIRE RECRUITMENT OF BOTH
INMATES AND OUTSIDERS. J. S.
BEGAN ACQUIRING WEAPONS AND
FINANCE OUR OPERATIONS THE
ROBBERIES. INVESTIGATION OF A
ROBBERY WITH THEIR IN DOING AS
THE LOCAL AGENCY WITHJURISDICTION. RECOGNIZE THE
POTENTIAL EXTREMIST CONNECTIONS
AND REPORTED THEIR SUSPICIONS.
THE FEDERAL AUTHORITY. AN
EXHAUSTIVE INVESTIGATION
CONDUCTED. BY THE FBI AND LAPD.
CDCR AND THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT AND EVERYTHING
NETWORK INCLUDING PLANS TARGETS
AND MEMBERSHIP. THE J. JAZZ
CASE PROMPTED NEW LOCAL
MEDICATION THAT. EFFORTS AND IN
RESPONSE TO THIS EVENT THE CDC
ARE NOW IS BECAUSE FOSTERED AND
IT RADICALIZATION PROGRAM
WITHIN THE GENERATOR YOUR
DESPERATE TO ADDRESS
CORRECTIONAL ISSUES ASSOCIATED
WITH THE CASE. THAT PROGRAM
CONTINUES TODAY WITH CONTINUOUS
TRAINING FOR CORRECTIONAL AND
HISTORY OF PERSONAL PROVIDED TO
RECOGNIZE ADDRESS AND REPORT
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. OF ANY TYPE
THE LOCAL FUSION CENTER. L. R.
IS UNFORTUNATELY HOME TO
SEVERAL DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
VICTIMS GROUPS. M. F. YEARS
SUCH AS THE **** LOW RIDERS
PUBLIC ENEMY NUMBER ONE RISE
ABOVE MOVEMENT NATIONAL
SOCIALIST AS WELL BLACK BLOC
ANARCHISTS AND MULTIPLE
SKINHEAD ORGANIZATIONS ALL HAVE
MEMBERS LIVING WITHIN THE JERK
AND MARK. THAT IS BECAUSE THEY
WERE PROCESSES PLEASE KEEP IN
MIND THAT THE CORE COMPETENCIES
MENTIONED ARE REPLICATED
THROUGHOUT THE CALIFORNIA
FUSION CENTER SYSTEM. ALBEIT
WITH LOCAL FLAVOR. JERICHO'S
WELL DEFINED PROTOCOLS FOR
ADDRESSING DVD IS USED WE ARE
NOT STICK TO THE POLITICS GOAL
OF OUR MAKE UP AND ANY GROUP. I
THINK JENNIFER ISLANDS. S.
PERPETRATED BY WORD OR DEED TO
CHARITIES AND IS INTERESTING.
BECAUSE I HAVE SUCH A JERK OF A
WIDER RESPONSIBILITY IT IS
CHALLENGING TO MAINTAIN
AWARENESS OF ALL THE THREATS
CONTAINED WITHIN THEIR WORK.
HOWEVER THE WHITE MAN ONCE SAID
IT TAKES A NETWORK TO DEFEAT A
NETWORK. UNDER THE TERRORISM.
OFFICER PROGRAM. THIS PROGRAM
WILL EVOLVE SINCE NINE ELEVEN
AND SHOULD BE RENAMED. A THREAT
LIAISON OFFICER PROGRAM. SINCE
THE GREAT MAJORITY OF FUSION
CENTERS OF ADOPTED THE ALL FOR
ITS APPROACH. MANY DEALER. AND
TRAINING IS THE BREAD AND
BUTTER OF NETWORK BUILDING. AND
INFORMATION SHARING. CALIFORNIA
EACH DEAL- NETWORK IS BUILT BY
THE LOCAL FUSION CENTER WITH A
PARTNERING AGENCIES AND
COORDINATE STATEWIDE. THROUGH
THE STATE PRESS OFTEN CENTER
MEDDLING FROM STATE TO STATE
YEAH THE NATIONAL CENTER
ASSOCIATION. WHICH REPRESENTS.
ALL EIGHTY CENTERS NATIONWIDE.
THE DEALER NETWORK AT MATH.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND SIX MADERA
ALONE HAS TRAINED MORE THAN
TWELVE THOUSAND FIRST
RESPONDERS FROM LAW FIRE HEALTH
AND THE PRIVATE SECTOR YOU KNOW
WHAT TO REPORT AND HOW TO
REPORT IT HOWEVER MINDFUL OF
PROTECTING PERSONAL PRIVACY AND
CIVIL LIBERTIES OF THE PUBLIC.
AFTER RECEIVING THIS TRAINING.
EACH TELEVISA TASKED WITH
PROVIDING THE SAME TRAINING TO
OTHER MEMBERS OF THEIR HOME
AGENCY DEPARTMENT OR COMPANY.
SPECIFICALLY ON DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE THREE MILLION THE
JERICHO VICE TRAINING ON
DEMOCRATIC REALIZATION
SOVEREIGN CITIZENS BEHAVIORAL
THREAT ASSESSMENT. AND
TARGETING SABOTAGE AND
DESTRUCTION. IT SHOULD BE
CLASSED AS APPROVED BY THE POST
COMMISSION ON. STANDARDS AND
TRAINING POST AND HELLO YES THE
APPROVALS ENSURE MATERIALS
RELEVANT CURRENT. AND
INSTRUCTORS ARE EXPERTS IN
THEIR FIELD. WELL SORRY THAT'S
THE PREFERRED OF THE FUSION
CENTERS IN JERICHO AND
ANALYTICAL CENTER WHICH MEANS
INTELLIGENCE PRODUCTION OF
PARAMOUNT. AS INDICATED
PREVIOUSLY THAT JARRETT SERVES
AT THE HUB BUT MY PARTNER GET
FUSION CENTERS DEAL FOR DALY
SUSPICIOUS ACTIVITY REPORTING.
JERRY BAIL ARE AVERAGES
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN TWELVE AND
FOURTEEN HUNDRED SUSPICIOUS
ACTIVITY REPORTS EACH YEAR. HR
IS A VALUE ADDED BY A TEAM OF
EXPERIENCED LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS. AND IF THE SARPANCH
TIONAL STANDARD IS MET. REPORT
IS QUICKLY TRANSMITTED TO OUR
PRO LOCATED AT THE ADDRESS
FOUGHT FOR IMMEDIATE ACTION. IS
NOT IMMINENT AND IRREPARABLE
REPORT AND BECAUSE THE
VALUATION FOR A FEDERAL STATE
OR LOCAL RESPONSE BASED ON
JURISDICTION. THE ACTIVITY PART
ABOUT TRAINING PURPOSES AND
BRETT. THAT REPORT AND SEVERAL
REPORTS ARE FORWARDED TO OUR
STRATEGIC ANALYSIS TELL ITS
PRODUCTION AND DISSEMINATION.
INFORMATION IS ALSO SHARED WITH
OUR BED AT DHS INTELLIGENCE
OFFICER WHO ALSO SERVED. ORANGE
COUNTY A FUSION CENTER AND THE
SAN DIEGO FUSION CENTER. JERRY
HALL HELLO THE SITUATION
WARRANTS WATCH WHICH FORWARDS
ALERTS NOTIFICATIONS OF REAL
TIME THREAT FOR PARTNERS AND
ALSO DEVELOP PRODUCTS FOR FIRST
RESPONDERS ON THE TACTICS.
TECHNIQUES AND PROCEDURES ARE
RECORDS ALL OF YOU CAN CENTER
THREE RECEIVE EACH OTHER
PRODUCTS. AND OTHER EVENTS
OCCUR WE SHARE CRITICAL
INVOLVING INFORMATION. VIA TEXT
PHONE CALLS EMAILS. WHATEVER IT
TAKES TO DEVELOP A STATEWIDE
SITUATIONAL AWARENESS ALL
TIMES. JERRY AND CONCERT WITH A
NETWORK OF KAYAK SHE SAID AND
THE SENATE ALONG HORSEMEN.
PERHATIAN CENTER CONTRIBUTED
THE ANNUAL STATEWIDE
PREDECESSOR NOW DISCUSSED BY A
PARTICULAR BG. AND AS FOR NAY
BY THE STACK. OFSTED'S PUTS
ALMOST ON THE SAME PAGE WHEN IT
COMES TO ASSIGNMENT OF
RESOURCES TO ADDRESS THE
THREATS THAT ARE COMMON
STATEWIDE. SO DID YOU EVER GET
ON THE PHONE CHALLENGES LOCAL
PRIORITIES BUT WE ARE PROUD
CONTRIBUTING MEMBER OF THE
STATE THREAT ASSESSMENT SYSTEM.
BUT HELLO YES EACH OF THE FIVE
INDEPENDENT FUSION CENTER
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION
STATEWIDE INITIATIVES.
REGARDING INFORMATION SHARING
RIGHT PERSPECTIVE FUNDING AND
ADMINISTRATION. MY RELIEF AS
THE NEW GUY THE STAFF SPENDS
THE GREAT MAJORITY OF ITS TIME
CONSOLIDATING. OPERATIONAL
ISSUES THAT IMPACT ON THE
PEOPLE CENTERS AS I SAID I AM
THE NEWEST EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
IN A SYSTEM. THAT DOES NOT MEAN
THAT DEREK IS NOT WELL
CONNECTED. ALL THE VISION
CENTERS THAT PRIOR LOT FUSIONS
AND RECORDS OF PRIOR LIFE AND
AGENCIES. I'VE KNOWN THE OTHER
TO THE CENTER'S DIRECTOR FOR
MANY YEARS TO ME THAT'S MY CURB
ALBERTO LESLIE. WE KNOW EACH
OTHER. AS A FORMER LESBIAN TALK
MANNER EMERGING MANAGER I'M
WELL ERSED ON CALIFORNIA'S
RESPONSIBILITY THE
CAPABILITIES. OF MIKE MCCARTHY
AND TOM OSBORNE OF AN EXTREMELY
SUPPORTIVE AND LEARN THE
BUSINESS I CONSIDER THEM
FRIENDS ALREADY. WELL MEET
REGULARLY TO SHARE CHALLENGES
AND SUCCESSES. THE TDP'S OF OUR
COMMON ADVERSARIES AND HE MAKE
THREATS ACTORS WITHIN OUR OWN
HOURS. THE CALIFORNIA SYSTEM
IT'S DEEP IN HISTORY IS VERY
WELL DEVELOPED AND CERTAIN.
DATA CALIFORNIA EXTREMELY WELL.
WHEN SCIENTIFIC OF THE LONGER
ANGELES FIELD. THE STAFF THE
END OF YOUR OTHER STATES SOME
SORT OF AS A MODEL. IT'S GONNA
SURELY CONFERENCE HAVE IN MY-
THE JERICHO. A STATE SYSTEM
THAT IS OF THE- NIMBLE.
EMPLOYEES FINEST. TEAM HAS BEEN
HUNDRED WITH NEW FORTY LONG.
THANK YOU BRING UP A JUST AND I
LOOK FOR ANY. THAT YOU HAVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
JOHNSON I WILL GO TO OUR FINAL
SPEAKER- WE'LL HEAR FROM MIKE.
SENIOR DIRECTOR OF THE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA REGIONAL THREAT
INTEGRATION CENTER- MIKE ARE
YOU THERE. I AM I AM AND ARE
YOU ABLE HERE. YES WE'RE HERE
FINE. MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MR BY
SEVERAL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
I'M MIKE CENTER FROM THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA REGIONAL
INTELLIGENCE CENTER AND TODAY-
I'M NOT GOING TO REHAB SOME OF
THE THINGS THAT WE TALKED
ABOUT- ALREADY TODAY YOUR
CLOSEST PARTNERS ARE THE FBI
JOINT TERRORISM TASK FORCE AND
FROM DHS DHS OFFICE AND TELL
THEM NOW THAT THAT HAS UNDER
DOESN'T BUCKLERS BANKRUPT
CALIFORNIA NAY NETWORK USUALLY
CENTERS. THAT CONNECT THE THREE
TOLD COMMUNITY AND WITHIN THE
FBI FRAMEWORK WE WORK CLOSELY
WITH THE TICKET YEAH YOU'LL
TELL THOSE GROUPS ON THE SIDE
WORKING THE PRIVATE SECTOR AT
ENGAGEMENT PARTNERSHIP CAME AS
WELL AS- OUR FRIENDS THAT WORK
OURSELVES- WITHIN OUR STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. NOW BROADER NETWORK
WHICH IS- TOTALED EIGHTY VIEWS
ON THE CROSS NATION ALLOW THAT
FACT THAT THE DATA AND
RESOURCES THAT PRIOR NINE
ELEVEN WE WOULD HAVE HAD ACCESS
TO I'VE BEEN ENGAGED IN THAT'S
NOT BEEN ASSIGNED TO THE
CONCERN THAT WORKS AND- TWO
WEEKS AFTER NINE ELEVEN BUT WE
SHOULD START BUILDING IT OUT.
AND I WANNA GIVE YOU ARE A
COUPLE OF DETAILS ONE IS A CASE
A RECENT CASE WERE- JUST THIS
LAST YEAR- A LOCAL SHERIFF'S
OFFICE UP IN NAPA AND THE FBI
RECEIVED TIPS FROM THE PUBLIC
BASICALLY THAT INDIVIDUAL WAS
ENGAGED IN A BATH REPLIED-
WEAPON THAT MADE DEATH THREATS.
AND AFTER A LENGTHY
INVESTIGATION WITH SUPPORT FROM
OUR DIGITAL PRINT THE KEVIN
FLAP ARE ANALYST- WE'RE ABLE TO
FIGURE OUT THAT- NEXT WEEK WITH
THE JD CARE UP AND THEIR HARD
WORK ABLE TO FIGURE OUT- THAT
THIS INDIVIDUAL ONE OF THE
MAPPING EQUIPMENT WHAT THE MATH
PEOPLE QUIET. AND ON JANUARY
FIFTEENTH- SEARCH WARRANT WAS
SERVED ON INDIVIDUALS HOME IN
NAPA CALIFORNIA AND IN THAT
HOME- THEY FOUND FORTY NINE
FIREARMS INCLUDING AUTOMATIC
WEAPONS FIVE BYE- SMOKELESS
POWDER- SURVIVAL MANUALS AND
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO MAKE
EXPLOSIVES BOB BODYARMOR
FIFTEEN THOUSAND ROUNDS OF
AMMUNITION. AND THAT PERSON- A-
TO US IN WITHOUT THAT PERSON
YEP ONE OF THEM LOCATED- WAS
FOUND THAT THEY WORKING. ABOUT
EIGHT PER RIGHT SEPARATE TO OUR
CAN- A THREAT TO A SPECIFIC
POLITICAL. TO MEMBERSHIP- BUT
THAT PERSON STOP THAT AND THAT
QUICK IT AND ALL THE- WE HAVE.
BY THE WAY HE DID HAVE A
PERCENT- NO. ON HER VEHICLE
WITH THE- OF IDEAS. A LOT OF
THIS WAS AS WE THOUGHT YOU WERE
SO IN THE THAT- WE'RE MAKING
NUMEROUS FOR. THAT WAS ONE OF
THOSE SPOKE THAT ARE OUT THERE
THAT. THANK FOR PUBLIC FOR. WE
FOUND THAT. NOW OTHER STORY
HAVE MADE ONE NINE- OF LAST.
OKAY EVEN CARILLO- TAKE A GHOST
GUN AND A R. NINE ERA FIFTEEN-
STYLE NINE MILLIMETER WEAPON.
AND CONTACT HIS FRIEND AND ASK
FOR SOMEONE TO HELP. THE PERSON
ANSWER THAT CALL ROBERT ALLEN
JUSTICE- AND YOU KNOW STEPHEN
CURRY OF THE PERSON THAT WAS
ARRESTED. BUT ONLY AFTER HE
EVADED LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
AGAIN. SOMEONE REPORTED SEEING
HIS VEHICLE AND SANTA CRUZ. AND
THEY FALL THAT VEHICLE UP TO A
RESIDENTIAL AREA WHERE HE GOT
INTO A GUN BATTLE AND THROUGH-
EXPLOSIVES THAT LONG COURSE
KILLING A THIRTY CUTS WYLER.
AND INJURING ANOTHER DEPUTY-
YEAH THANKS TO THOSE RECORDS
THAT WERE SEIZED BUT OUR ROLE
IN IN. THIS WHOLE EFFORT. IN
THE COLLECTIVE FORMATION. WHAT
ARE PARTNERS WITH. EVERYTHING
FROM REAL TIME OPEN IN OUR- TO
COORDINATION OSAMA COPY ARE.
OPRET POLITE íORTING A
PROJECT WE START IN TWO
EIGHTEEN. WHERE THERE PROVIDE
US WITH THE STEPS. INSPECTOR
REPORT. DIRECTLY TOWARDS. AND
BACK WE'VE BEEN ON ONE FOR THE
LAST HOUR THAT WE RECEIVED
ACTUALLY FROM THE NATIONAL PARK
OPERATIONS CENTER OUR FBI
PARTNERS ARE ALSO PART OF THIS
PROJECT. BUT IT TAKES A WHOLE
COMMUNITY THANKS PUBLIC
REPORTING IT TAKES THAT
INFORMATION GETTING THE LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT. HAPPY WITH THE
PERMISSION TO US AND THE STAFF
ACROSS ALL OF OUR FUSION
CENTERS. THAT WAY WE CAN
PROCESS THAT LOOK AT THE
CONNECTIONS ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
AND THROUGH OUR PARTNERS IN THE
BILL CAN BE TENS OF ACROSS THE
WORLD. BUT IF THIS CAPACITY
THAT WE HAVE BUILT. ON A LOT
NOT BEEN WORKING ON ALLTHESE
YEARS IN THE PARTNERSHIP THE
RELATIONSHIPS THAT WE BUILT. TO
IDENTIFY THOSE THREATS WHILE
PROTECTING PRIVACY THE RIGHTS
OF LIBERTY. TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE GOING AFTER PEOPLE FOR
CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR THAT WE'RE
GOING AFTER PEOPLE FOR THE
SUSPICIOUS BEHAVIOR THAT'S BEEN
IDENTIFIED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. AS PRE INCIDENT
INDICATORS ATTACK. ANY TO
STORIES BUT ONE WHERE THE
INDIVIDUAL STOP THE NAPA-
THAT'S THE TACK THAT
POTENTIALLY COULD HAVE GONE
HORRIBLY WRONG. THE STOCK
BECAUSE THE PUBLIC REPORT AND
BECAUSE OF THE GOOD WORK OF THE
FBI DID YEAH THE COORDINATION
WITH ALL OF OUR PARTNERS. AND
OUR ROLE IS ALSO- RESPONDING TO
THESE EVENTS. RECORDING EVENTS
AND- REALLY FACILITATE
INFORMATION SHARING WITH OUR
PARTNERS IN THE FBI BOTH FOR
OUR REGION- THROUGH OUR STATE
AND ACROSS THE NATION. THANK
EVERYONE FOR THE TIME TODAY I
KNOW THAT OUR TIME IS UP. AND I
APPRECIATE THAT- ANSWERING ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE. I
THANK YOU FOR MY- REALLY TO ALL.
THE FOLKS FOR PER. IN OUR TEST.
HERE THE SECOND PANEL. OF THE
C. AS WE- PRETTY MUCH A THE END
OF. OUR TO OUR BUT WE STILL
HAVE A FEW LEFT. SOME COURSE
SUCH HAD TWO QUICK QUESTIONS I
JUST WANTED. TO BRING ABOUT IN
HERE FROM WHEREVER. COULD GIVE
ME SOME ANSWERS ONE OF IS.
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC AND
WHAT IS DONE TO US AS A STATE
IN HOW WE OPERATE- AND COMING
OUT OF IT THIS YEAR WERE THE
MAJOR OBSTACLES. DEALING WITH
THE PANDEMIC ON TOP OF WHAT YOU
GUYS DO ALREADY. MONITORING
THREATS AND RESPONDING TO
MAKING SURE THAT- WE HAVE THE
NECESSARY RESOURCES TO COMBAT
THE ISSUES. FOR WONDER FOR TO-
OTHER THAN FUNDING AS WELL AS
THE FUNDING TO IMPROVE
ORGANIZATIONS. ANYTHING THAT
HERE THAT THE LEGISLATURE CAN
DO TO HELP YOU FOLKS IN THE
JOBS YOU DO TO PROTECT US IN
CALIFORNIA. A REFER ANYBODY IF
ANYBODY COULD GIVE ME A QUICK-
DR ON THAT OR ANYTHING. I CAN
DOT I DON'T THINK THE TRAINING
TO IF THAT'S IF THAT'S OF
INTEREST SO THE TRAINING
OBVIOUSLY TOOK A TOOK A BIG HIT
OVER THE LAST YEAR. I THINK AND
JEREMIAH CANNELLA FUSIONS ARE
DOING A LOT OF TRAINING BUT
VERY SOCIALLY DISPENSED MEETING
ALL CDC GUIDELINES. HONORS AT
ONE TIME EDWARD FIFTEEN OR
TWENTY WOULD BE TRYING TO KEEP
IT GOING BUT- MATT RELATED OF I
DON'T DROVE DOWN THE NUMBER OF
THE PROJECT- ACT REPORTS
WORRIES ONE OR- FORTY HUNDRED
TO TWO. SIX- SORRY AGENCY HERE
YOU EVER- AND LET YEAR WAS NINE
SOMETHING SO THE PER ONE NOW
GAS WERE. I THINK WERE. SO THAT
PART BECAUSE I COUPLE BIT- AND
I IT IS BECAUSE THE NUMBERS ARE
STARTING TO COME SALAS UP A TRY
SIDE OF MY COMPETITION COME ON
THE. S. AND MY WOULD BE. THE
THAT. WITH OSAMA COMPANIES- YOU
KNOW THEY IS NO REQUIRE THAT
THREE. ANY THREATS TO LAW
COURSE UNLESS IT INVOLVES. A
THE EXPERT TRADE EXPORTS OF
AFFECT WHAT. OF A CHILD. SO
WHEN WE LOOK AT YOU KNOW SOME
THE LARGE COMPANIES. IN THE FOR
SOCIAL MEDIA. ATTEMPTING TO CAL.
AND BELIEVE ME WE COME ALL WAY
TO TWENTY EIGHT PARTNER OF THE
CAR. ON EVERY FOR TRY ACCORDING
COLLAPSE. BUT WE WILL AT THE
WORLD AND YOU. THE EVERYTHING
YOU'VE DONE SOCIAL. SO THAT
THAT ARE ON. HAVE NOT SLOWED
DOWN BAD THAT MAKES WE'VE BEEN
DEALING WITH THE- EVERY DAY.
BUT NO ONE HAS GONE TO EXAM.
YOU KNOW HOW DO WE- WANNA FACT
AND CALL. THE REPORTING THAT WE
SHOULD GET FROM SOCIAL COMPANY.
AND THE IN BECAUSE THERE ARE NO
STATUTE IT AND I KNOW THAT MAY
BE A- A NATIONAL- ISSUE BUT THE
GREAT THING THAT CONVERSATION
STATE WHILE. HOW DO WE- THE-
COURT. ON THE TYPES OF AND
LINKS. DAN HOW IMPORTANT IT IS.
FOR US TO KEEP A LID. ON ON
WHAT WE'RE DOING BECAUSE I
THINK- POSTING TO GET
COMPLACENT THE FARTHER AWAY YOU
GET FROM FROM A MAJOR INCIDENT
LIKE NINE ELEVEN. I J. THE MORE
COMPLACENT PEOPLE COME N. AND
WHEN YOU'RE DOING A REALLY GOOD
JOB THEY DON'T KNOW THAT YOU'RE
DOING THAT GOOD JOB. AND AND
THEN THERE'S A TENDENCY FOR
PEOPLE TO SAY. YOU KNOW WE
DON'T NEED TO BE DOING THAT
ANYMORE AND- AND WHEN I THINK-
THE TESTIMONY TODAY POINTS TO
THE FACT THAT. THIS IS JUST ONE
LAYER OF. LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT
HAS TO CONTINUE TO- TO EXIST AT
THE LEVELS AND EVEN MORE SO- IN
ORDER TO KEEP. OUR PEOPLE SAFE
AND THAT'S WHAT THESE
COMMITTEES ARE ABOUT THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE. ARE WE
WANT TO PUBLIC TO BE SAFE
PEOPLE SHOULD BE ABLE TO WALK
THE STREET THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE
TO BE A FENCE AROUND THE
CAPITAL. OF THOSE TYPE OF
THINGS AND- SO THANK YOU FOR
ALL YOU DO AND- MISTER STAB ME
WITH NICE TO SEE YOU AGAIN I
HAVEN'T SEEN WHO PROBABLY FOR
TEN YEARS. THEY ACTUALLY USED
TO WORK SOMETIMES WITH THE
SHERIFF'S- BUT- BUT ANY RATE
VERY VERY INFORMATIVE TODAY AND
I APPRECIATE. YOU GUYS TAKING
THE TIME TO DAY TO SPEND WITH
US. THANK YOU A SENATOR LOOKS
LIKE DO YOU HAVE A QUESTION.
DID MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU I
WANTED TO SEE IF WE CAN GET-
TWITTER DUDE SHE- AND ANY OF
OUR- OUR READ. HEADS COMMENTS
ON THE BY MINISTRY ANNOUNCED WE
KNOW SECRETARY MIGHT WORK IS
PUT OUT OF TODAY. ANNOUNCING
NEW NEW- ENTIRE INTEL TO BE.
WITHIN THE HOMELAND SECURITY
FOCUS. ON EXTREMISM. AS WELL AS
A- IT SOUNDS LIKE A- MORE WITH
SOCIAL MEDIA COME TO DO NOT.
NECESSARILY ENHANCE TRADE OR
SURVEILLANCE BUT INSTEAD REALLY
BE FOCUSING ON- ABILITIES TO
IDENTIFY TRENDS OR TIPS- AND
REALLY BEAT UP OUR CAPABILITIES
THEIR PARTNERSHIP WITH- IT WITH
THE PRIVATE SECTOR- ANY
COMMENTS THERE IT SEEMS LIKE
THERE'S GOING TO BE A FOCUS ON
BUILDING UP STATE LOCAL
CAPACITY SO I WAS ENCOURAGED BY
THE ANNOUNCEMENT I JUST. WASN'T
SURE IF YOU AT ANY INITIAL
COMMENTS. ALL THE SMART AMID AS
MY BECAUSE I YOU KNOW MY-
OBVIOUS IS PRESENT. FEW CENTER
SAYS SHE- HAS HAS REALLY WORKED
HARD IN DC ON ON THIS TOPIC
AND- YOU KNOW MAYBE HAVE MIKE
START OFF AND THEN I HAVE A
COUPLE COMMENTS ON IT SO. NO
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
REALLY APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT
FROM MARKELLE EUGENE THEY'RE
THE DIRECT AND- BUT I DID WANT
TO THAT YOU KNOW WHEN YOU. AT
MEDICARE MISSED PROBLEM. AN
ORGANIZATION LIKE THE PARK NOT
SECURITY AND ESPECIALLY ON THE
ROLE I MENTIONED EARLIER THAT
THEY HAVE. AS A CONDUIT TO THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY. PAUL
THEY'RE A LOT OF CAPITA ON THE
INTEL COMMITTEE THE ROLE THEY
PLAY. AND DOMESTIC TERROR. AND
THINGS WITHIN THE UNITED STATES
SO EXPANDING OF. AND THE GREAT
THANKS A US TO HAVE A NOTHER
RESOURCE TO HELP WITHOUT IN
UNDER BUT BY. SB ACROSS THE-
OUT THE HEARTS THOUGH THAT
THEIR STAFF IN THE RE. THEY
HAVE THAT MATCH AT WITH WHAT
THE PEOPLE AND CALIFORNIA FOR
ON THE XEON. OF DATA NAY IT
REALLY REDUCE YA HOW MANY
BODIES WE HAVE A THE STATE.
THANK TWELVE PEOPLE THAT
THOUGHT THAT WHAT WE GOT AND-
REALLY THE NEED TO BE A- OF.
FROM DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
SECURITY AND I NEED TO BE AT
THE LAW THEY NEED BE AT THE-
OUT. HAVING FOLKS IN THE COME
UP WITH. NO PROB IS NOT LIKE
HAVING SOME HERE THAT SITTING
IN A FUSION- THAT'S WITH OURS
OAKLAND BART OTHER FEDERAL
PARTNERS. TO DEVELOP PRODUCTS
SO I THINK THIS IS A GOOD FOR
OUR CERTAIN. I BUT I THINK THAT
JUST STARTING POINT THAT WE
NEED A MORE TIME TO. THAT YOU
KNOW THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WILL FLOW- STATE MUCHAS- BY
WILL TAKE A FIVE TO GET THOSE.
HERE BUT I THINK IT'S VERY
ENCOURAGING. AND YOU'RE HAVING.
UP TO ALL OF THESE FOLKS
DECIDED- WE JUST I'M AYE AYE
PART SEEN. PAS MOVEMENTS THE A-
UNDER THIS NEW IMAGE. OP ON
THIS KIND OF THING AND PUTTING
PUTTING RESOURCES BEHIND. A AT
IT. THEY'RE ACTUALLY STARTING
FROM A NEGATIVE NUMBER LET'S BE
CLEAR ON THAT AND THEY'RE
TRYING TO. RAMP UP AS FAST AS
THEY CAN- BUT ALL OF THE
DISCUSSIONS WE HAVE WITH THEM
SEEM TO BE MORE. IN A POSITIVE
DIRECTION- BUT IT DOESN'T
NEGATE THE FACT THAT- THAT
THREAT IT IS. HERE IT IS NOW IT
IS REAL AND IT IS HAPPENING AND
SO. WERE WORKING DOUBLE TRIPLE
TIME- TO FILL THE GAP AND IN
DOWN. YOU KNOW- AS THE CULTURE
MENTIONED- THE WORK IN THE
FUTURE SENATE YOU KNOW YOU MAY
NOT SEE THIS ON- OUR ON THE
NEWS EVERY NIGHT BUT THE WORK
OF THE FUSION CENTERS BEHIND
THE SCENES. INSURING THAT. YOU
KNOW YOU THERE'S MORE OF THESE
EVENTS THAT ARE REWARDED
BECAUSE OF THE WORK OF THE
FUSION CENTERS. THAT ARE
ACTUALLY TAKING THAT THERE
WON'T BE A HAPPY. OCCASIONALLY
THE GONNA HAVE. WE A LOT. OUT
US IT'LL OF GOOD LEVELS- I
CAN'T. HIGHLY WITHOUT FOR THE
WORK THEY DO. AND HOW THEY CAN.
AND COLLABORATE WITH WITH LOCAL
LAW FOR- BUT BUT- IT CAN ONLY
GO SO FAR- AND SO YOU NEED
THOSE RESOURCES TO. THE
AMPLIFIER AND THE STATE
CURRENT. AND FRESH IN IN BEING
ABLE TO EVALUATE THE ONGOING
INCOMING THREATS OF THE SHORE
AT SENATOR IS. REALLY
ENCOURAGED BY THE- DHS'S MOVE.
AND LOOK FORWARD TO HOLD-
ENHANCING AND AN APPLE. OUR
RESOURCES. CALIFORNIA THANKS
FOR THAT FEEDBACK AND THANKS ME
CHAIR AGAIN FOR THE A FOR THE
INDULGE HERE ON THE QUESTION I
KNOW THAT. SECURE MY IS GOING
BEFORE SENATE. COMMITTEE I
BELIEVE TIME. IN USA- SO
HOPEFULLY WE'LL SEE SOME GOOD.
AND I WOULD I WOULD SAY. I MEAN
THE VERY IN. IN WHAT WE CAN DO
EVEN ON A BI. BASIS HERE TO
ADVOCATE WITH THEIR
COUNTERPARTS IN WASHINGTON- TO
REALLY MAKE THIS A PRIORITY AND
NOT TAKE TOO LONG IN THE START
UP PROCESS BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW.
YEAH I MEAN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT THOUSANDS OF STARS OUT
THERE FOR. LESS THAN A DOZEN
PEOPLE. YOU CAN'T KEEP UP AND
YOU CAN'T CAN THE DOTS QUICKLY
ENOUGH SO IT'S BEEN A SOBRE.
BETTER TESTIMONY FROM YOU
ALWAYS. SINCERELY APPRECIATE
WHAT YOU DO TO KEEP US SAFE AND
FOR ALL THINGS- THAT. THAT- ARE
NOT REPORTED ON- BUT BUT
HOPEFULLY- HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET
THIS MESSAGE BACK TO WASHINGTON
TO MAKE SOME PROGRESS THIS YEAR.
THANKS BERMAN CENTER FOR YOUR
INPUT AND WITH THAT I WANT TO
THANK ALL OF TODAY'S- OUR FOLKS
ARE PRESENTED IN YOUR TESTIMONY
OR PARTICIPATION A MEANS A LOT
NOT ONLY TO MEET THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND- I'LL BE TO ALL OF
US IN CALIFORNIA- LIKE SAID WE
DON'T KNOW EXACTLY ALL THE WORK
YOU DO. THE HARD WORK YOU DO
DAY IN AND DAY OUT TWENTY FOUR
HOURS A DAY. EVERY THROUGHOUT
THROUGHOUT THE WHOLE YEAR SO
THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN AND KEEP
US IN MIND OF- AS THINGS MOVE
FORWARD HOW WE CAN BE OF
ASSISTANCE TO MAKE SURE THAT.
YOU HAVE THE NECESSARY
RESOURCES TO YOUR JOB
EFFECTIVELY EVERY DAY. SO
WITHOUT- DUE TO TIME
CONSTRAINTS WE'RE GOING TO
LIMIT PUBLIC- COMMENT TO ONLY
FIVE WITNESSES. I KNOW THERE
MAY BE SOME FOLKS ON THE LINE
I'M NOT SURE BUT I THINK THERE
ARE MAYBE. A FEW FOLKS HERE IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM SO THAT WILL
LIMIT TO ONE MINUTE PER PERSON
SO IF THERE'S ANYBODY HERE. IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME AND YOU ONLY HAVE ONE
MINUTE. CAN I PLEASE HAVE TWO
MINUTES- ONE. ONE MINUTE MINUTE
GHOST. YOU HAVE YOUR TIME
DISCARDED NOW STATE YOUR NAME
AND- AND YOUR ONE MINUTE. MY
NAME'S KATHERINE PRIVATE. LAST
WEEK I WAS CUT OFF TWICE. THE
CENTRIST OF NEEDS TO STOP
FREDDIE RODRIGUEZ AND ALL OF
YOU. NEED TO STAND UP FOR OUR
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS. THE
DEATH RATE FROM COVERED
NINETEEN OVER FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND IS OVERBLOWN. DR
BROOKS ADMITTED IT LAST YEAR.
DOES FROM WITH COVER THE SAME
IS DEATH OF COATED ON DEATH
CERTIFICATES- THEY'RE GOOD
TREATMENTS AND PROTOCOLS. THAT
DON'T INVOLVE INJECTING
SUBSTANCES LIKE RECOMBINANT
REPLICATION DEFICIT DEFICIENT
CHIMPANZEE ADENOVIRUS VECTOR
ENCODING THE STARS COVE TO.
SPIKE GLYCOPROTEIN PRODUCED IN
GENETICALLY MODIFIED HUMAN
EMBRYONIC KIDNEY CELLS. OVER
THE COUNTER. TREATMENTS ARE
BEING SUPPRESSED. TO JUSTIFY
THE EXPERIMENTAL GEL OKAY NO
VACCINE FOR THIS VIRUS IS FDA
APPROVED ALL THE FAIR IT'S AN
INITIAL STUDIES DIED WHEN
EXPOSED TO SERVE US OUR SCHOOL
ONE. DOCTORS ARE SPEAKING OUT
OF AND THIS IS LIKE GOING TO BE
LIKE A NATIONAL NATIONWIDE.
AIDS EPIDEMIC OKAY- OKAY TAKE
YOUR TIME IS UP NEXT PERSON. SO
I'M TALLER THAN SHE IS MISTER
TURNER FOR THE RECORD PLEASE
MOM I'D LIKE I I'D LIKE FULL
MIKE PLEASE AM I ALLOWED TO
TOUCH IT OR DOES IT HAVE CODED
YOUR ONE BECAUSE ACCORDING TO
YOUR FIRST WITNESS TOM O'CONNOR
SPECIAL FBI RETIRED AGENT.
TURNED ON THE PHONE PLEASE.
VAXXERS APPEAR NOW CONSIDERED
DOMESTIC TERRORISTS AND SO THE
MILLION DOLLAR QUESTION WAS
ASKED IN THIS HEARING HOW TO
GOVERN IN SUCH A WAY THAT IT
DOES NOT CAUSE PEOPLE TO ACT
OUT. AND I THINK I MAY HAVE
SOME INSIGHT FOR YOU AS A
VACCINE INJURED GOAT FARMER
MOTHER OF FOUR WHO HAS BEEN IN
THIS BUILDING A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY TIMES. GIVING TESTIMONY
IN DOZENS OF HEARINGS
CALIFORNIA CODE TWO FOUR ONE
SEVEN ONE THE RIGHT FOR ME TO
DECIDE FOR MYSELF WHAT HAPPENS
TO MY OWN BODY. THE LAW SAYS
THAT I MAY NOT BE COERCED INTO
DOING ANYTHING AGAINST MY
WISHES NO ONE MADE WORSE ME.
WELL NEVER. THE SERGEANTS AND
YOUR ADDRESS THE. OPERATOR WE
GO TO FOCUS ON THE PHONE SO WE
ONLY HAVE TIME FOR MORE. SO FAR
DINNER DRESSED. THE SPEAKER
SERGEANT CAN. OPERATOR DO WE
ANY ON THE LINE WE ONLY HAVE
TIME FOR THREE MORE FOLKS EVERY
THREE FOR ON THE LINE. SURE IF
YOU HAVE A PUBLIC. YOU NEED TO
PUSH ONE OF THEN ZERO. NOW WILL
GET YOU INTO THE QUEUE THAT'S.
ONE NINE ZERO. WE DO ONE UP A
CALM OR QUESTION HERE WILL BE
TO ONE MORE WHILE WE GET THE
NOT NUMBER. ONCE AGAIN THAT IS
ONE THEN ZERO FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. HELLO IS ANYBODY THERE
JUST ONE MOMENT HERE YEP I'M
SORRY JUST ONE MOMENT HERE
WE'RE WAITING FOR THE LINE
NUMBER AND WE WILL CALL TWO
LINE NUMBER. AT THE. TWELVE
OKAY WE WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER
TWO YOUR LIFE IS OPEN. AND
HELLO. CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES THE
TURNER FOR THE RECORD YOU HAVE
ONE MIN THANK YOU. HI MY NAME
IS WENDY B. L. I'M- IN I.
PRETTY CAN. ABOUT BUT I'VE
HEARD TODAY THE MEETING. IT
WILL HEARTBREAKING TO ME. AND-
THE LAST COUNT SHE GOT PRETTY
UNLESS. IF REALLY HARPER TO ME
THAT. MOTHER ARE CONSIDERED TO
BE TERRORISTS BECAUSE- THEY
HAVE YOU KNOW CHILDREN THAT
THEY DON'T WANT BACK WITH THE
CO IN FACT THAT IS A
EXPERIMENTAL BACK NOT AT
AIRPORT. I JUST REALLY DISTURB
FROM THE PAST THAT I HEARD- TOM
CONNOR I BELIEVE. HE IS FROM
MARS AT. IT IT IT. URGING AND
THAT. THE CRICKETING MIGHT IS.
WHO YOUR THREE OF THEM TERROR
ARE WREAKING GUY THE. NO ONE
ELSE. REMOVE HER FROM. OPERATOR
ANYONE ELSE. OPERATOR AND WHEN
I DON'T WANT ANYBODY ELSE THANK
YOU. ANYBODY ON. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH APPROVED. WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED
THANK YOU.